Ist schon irgendjemand da wahrscheinlich?
Ich weiß ich bin heute früh, ich weiß nicht wie lange ich am Start bin.
Ich hole mir schnell was zu trinken, warte mal
Leute ich weiß nicht wie lange ich heute da bin, mal gucken, ich bin heute relativ früh,
ich weiß aber mal gucken wie lange geschrieben wird, ich habe noch nichts gegessen oder so.
Ist die Woche irgendwas spannendes passiert, was ich nicht mitgekriegt habe, war irgendwas,
außer dass Microsoft ein Microsoft-Kontopflicht einführen will in Windows 11, sonst war die
Woche glaube ich relativ wenig oder, also mir fällt wenigstens nichts ein.
So, das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, tschüss, tschüss.
Also wir gucken uns jetzt ein paar Videos zusammen an und schauen ob YouTube uns irgendetwas
den Volles empfiehlt, ich bin doch müde, ja und ich weiß gar nicht was ich großartig
sagen soll, außer dass ich gerade aufgestanden bin vor 5 Minuten oder so.
Ja, und dass der Stream heute nicht so lange geht, mal gucken wie lange ich es aushalte,
aber mir tut der Hals irgendwie ein bisschen weh und ich muss es nicht übertreiben, das
soll möglichst schnell wieder weg, oh nein es wird höchstwahrscheinlich nicht Corona
sein, lull, ey wahrscheinlich kein Corona, also ich bin ja mittlerweile triple, triple
Antennen geimpft, das zweite Mal war gar nicht so wild, das war vor genau einer, also
ziemlich genau einer Woche, außer, also diesmal hatte ich noch nicht mal Kopfweh großartig,
mir hat zwei Tage der Armweh getan und dann war weg, nichts mehr vongemerkt, vielleicht
liegt es, dass mir jetzt der Hals weh tut noch daran, keine Ahnung, kann ja sein, hoffentlich,
aber man sollte durch eine Corona-Impfung eigentlich kein Corona kriegen, das wäre ziemlich bescheuert.
Sonst wäre ja das irgendwie ziemlich Booster, ja das war, vor einer Woche habe ich meinen
Booster gekriegt.
Achja, so ich muss mal kurz was gucken, kurz hier Fullscreen aus, gab es irgendwelche wichtigen
IT-Geschichten die Woche, wo ich vergessen habe, Transportschiff ist mir wurscht, juckt
mich auch nicht, juckt mich auch nicht, juckt mich auch nicht, achja das fand ich witzig,
das habe ich gelesen, irgendein Typ in Frankreich, irgendein Typ in Frankreich hat es abgefuckt,
dass seine Kinder so viel abends im Internet surfen, also hat er sich über irgendein Forum
oder so einen Störsender gekauft, irgendein Jammer und das hat dafür gesorgt, dass das
Handyzeug und sowas in der kompletten Umgebung nicht funktioniert hat, das ist auch richtig
angeblieben, das ist, der Typ ist in irgendein Forum gegangen und die haben ihm aber was
empfohlen.
Ja gut, dass Nibahn mit Problemen mit Stürme hat, wissen wir, Nibahn hat aber auch ohne
Stürme Probleme.
Oh da muss man kurz, wenn uns das schon empfohlen, wir bewerben uns, easy Bewerbung, auf geht's,
Bewerbung ist raus.
Ego stellt Bausatz von Erloy und Langehals vor, da gibt es einen Horizon Zero, nee Forbidden
West ist es jetzt ja, Bausatz, da kannst du dir Heltersteine wieder auskotzen drüber,
dass es wahrscheinlich viel zu teuer ist, das was man bekommt, wer hat das kürzeste
Netzwerkkabel?
Reddit, na gut, da muss man gar nicht weiter fragen, Salando Deliverio, ok es gibt nichts
spannendes.
Ja ja, die Telekom, die Telekom rät wahrscheinlich ihre eigene, ist das nicht dieser geile Telekom
Gaming Router mit Gaming WLAN, wo sie sagen, es ist, wie war das da, da leuchtet die Bude,
nee ich krieg's gar nicht mehr zusammen, was sie erzählt haben, das war so ein Cringe
Video.
Ok sieht normal aus.
Nee, nichts spannendes, ok, so noch mal refreshen, Youtube irgendwas einem ordentliches vorschlagen
kann, wenn nicht lassen wir uns jetzt, vielleicht lassen wir uns eine Runde LevelCapture baiten,
komm wir lassen uns eine Runde LevelCapture baiten, naja ob das was wird, Leute ich hab
WW3 mittlerweile deinstalliert und ich werde das auch nicht mehr installieren und wisst
ihr warum?
Weil ich keinen Bock auf MailRU Anti-Cheat hab, das ist wirklich der hauptsächliche
Grund, warum ich nicht mehr reingucke, klar, im Prinzip kannst du sagen, ob das nun Anti-Cheat
von Amis ist oder Anti-Cheat von Russen, ist doch eigentlich egal, die malen wahrscheinlich
das gleiche, aber ich weiß nicht, irgendwie traue ich MailRU Anti-Cheat noch weniger als
anderem Anti-Cheat.
Aus dem Grund dürfte man eigentlich auch kein Valorant spielen, Valorant ist ja China-Chinesen
Anti-Cheat, aber ich weiß nicht, MailRU Anti-Cheat hat mich irgendwie nicht so geschockt.
Vor allem, weißt du was das Schlimmste war, dass es keinen Uninstall Knopf dafür gibt?
Du konntest das Game und den Anti-Cheat nicht deinstallieren, du musstest das von Hand
removeen und dann habe ich mir auch gedacht, leck mich, dann ist vorbei, das installiere
ich mir nicht nochmal.
Oh ja, ich bin echt müde, immer noch, deswegen waren wir jetzt ja auch auf Wachstream und
wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht wie lange das Stream heute geht.
So, lasst uns mal eine Runde mit Musik lauter machen, hat mir ja kaum was, vielleicht klickt
es am Hubsanit.
Ja, der S ist wieder gleich viel lauter, jetzt werden die Playlists sich nicht entscheiden
können und das nicht normalisieren, die Lautstärke, komm wir gucken uns eine Runde Level Cap an,
wir lassen Level Cap jebaiten, auf geht's.
Ja gut, EA, habt ihr das mitbekommen, EA hat responded und hat gesagt, Halo ist daran schuld,
dass Battlefield so gefloppt ist, ausgerechnet Halo, ich meine, es ist jetzt nicht so, als
hätte Halo so die, ich meine, der Multiplayer war im Vergleich zu dem was sonst zu dieser
Zeit rausgekommen ist tatsächlich ganz spaßig, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, als würde Halo
die Millionen Leute hier da irgendwie ansprechen, das ist komplett, glaube ich mal komplett,
also ich glaube, aber ich bin da relativ sicher, komplett andere Leute auch, die das anspricht,
ich meine, du kannst ein Battlefield nicht mit so einem Halo Multiplayer vergleichen
und das ist einfach nur ganz billige Ausrede, zumal sie ja sogar zugeben mussten, Halo war
besser polished als Battlefield, ich meine, das ist alles mehr oder weniger besser polished
als Battlefield 2042, guckt euch, ich meine, ok, Cyberpunk vielleicht nicht, aber ansonsten
ist ja fast, ich meine, das ist tatsächlich schwer, das zu unterbieten, weil viele Games,
die heutzutage rauskommen, sind ja schon broken, aber Battlefield 2042 hat noch was drauf,
aber wir müssen übrigens Spielerzahlen gucken, wo wir gerade dabei sind, machen wir sonntags
doch auch immer, New World Spielerzahlen.
Ok, das geht immer weiter abwärts, das ist so schlecht, Alter, von der Million runter
auf 40k, das ist so mies, und wisst ihr noch, was ich am Anfang gesagt habe, ich habe am
Anfang gesagt, die Leute werden sich zurücksehnen nach der Zeit, wo sie Warteschlangen hatten
für Server, weil heute sind ihre Server einfach leer und keine Sau ist drauf, ja, Gilden
sind wahrscheinlich dead, Leute sind irgendwie mit 5 Spieler über 500 Server verteilt.
Boah, ist das schlecht, Alter, ist das schlecht, ich muss mal kurz gucken, Twitch, New World,
der größte Zuschauer hat tatsächlich immer 128 Zuschauer, das ist herbegegangen, also,
New World ist wirklich ein Paradebeispiel dafür, wie man es verkacken kann.
New World ist das einzige MMO, das mir so einfällt, also, wir klammern mal die MMOs aus, wo du
dich einloggst und sofort weißt, es ist scheiße, ja, irgendwelche billigen China-Chinesen-Free-to-Play-Dinger
oder sowas in der Richtung, ja, also, MMOs, wo du dich einloggst und sofort weißt, es
ist scheiße, klammern wir mal aus, aber Lost Ark ist das einzige MMO, was ich kenne, dass
umso länger du es spielst, umso schlechter es wird, wird es, die meisten MMOs fangen
ganz okay an, weil sie irgendwie die Spieler erhalten müssen und umso länger du dich damit
beschäftigst, umso mehr du in die Welt reinkommst, umso mehr du in die Skills, in die Mechanics
reinkommst, umso mehr du Content machst, umso besser wird es eigentlich, nicht New World,
New World fängt relativ gut an, bleibt dann 10 Stunden ganz okay, im Mittelfeld immer
noch spielbar, aber, sag mal, spätestens ab der 100-Stunden-Marke ist es dann eigentlich
kaum noch erträglich, was für den MMO ja nichts ist und deswegen rennen die Leute auch
reihenweise weg, also, sie haben es echt geschafft, ein MMO zu bauen, was umso länger du es spielst,
umso schlechter wird, Wahnsinn, Wahnsinn, Endgame gibt es ja anscheinend immer noch
nicht richtig, also im Prinzip ist das eingetreten, was ich in meinem New World Video schon prediktet
habe, obwohl ich nur die Beta gespielt habe zu dem Zeitpunkt, aber ich finde, das war
abzusehen und in dem Video haben ja alle gesagt, oh Max, du machst das Game so schlecht, du
weißt doch gar nicht, wie es wird, das kannst du doch gar nicht wissen, jetzt red mal, das
Game nicht so schlecht, immer die gleiche Scheiße, die gleiche Scheiße, die ich auch
jedes Mal höre, wenn ich mir irgendwie eine Battlefield Call of Duty, sonst was Beta angucke,
ich kann euch im Prinzip schon meistens relativ genau sagen, was da im Ende rauskommt, ich
meine klar, ich habe auch schon wie bei Rainbow Six total in die Scheiße gegriffen, da habe
ich komplett falsch gelegen, muss man ja auch mal sagen, aber immer das Gleiche, könnt
ihr euch noch dran erinnern, Battlefield 2042 Beta, wo die Leute gesagt haben, das Bild,
das ist Monate alt, das ist doch nur eine Beta Max, jetzt geh doch mal nicht davon aus,
dass das Spiel in diesem Zustand rauskommt, das ist nur ein Test, das echte Spiel wird
dann viel besser und jeder, jeder der die letzten Jahre bisschen im Gaming Bereich unterwegs
war, der muss eigentlich klar gewesen sein, das ist Bullshit, all die Leute so richtig
Copium Style, also New World am abkacken weiterhin, haben wir gesehen, GG Eats und das ist ja nur
wirklich, das ist ja nur wirklich nicht mehr, in irgendeiner Art und Weise von TheAce schön
zu reden, oder?
Ich meine von 100.000, ich meine, ok, ok, es ist nur Steam, das muss ich ja immer Disclaimer
mäßig dabei sagen, weil sonst kommen die Leute wieder und sagen, Max, aber Steam alleine
ist doch nicht aussagekräftig, naja, die Sache ist halt die, warum sollte der Trend auf Konsolen
und auf nicht Steam großartig anders aussehen, selbst wenn er nicht ganz so steil ist, er
wird ähnlich sein, sollte er das nicht sein, wird mich mal die Begründung dafür erklären,
warum man denkt, dass es nicht so ist, aber das musst du erstmal schaffen, von 100.000,
100.000 Spielern auf Steam, runter auf 3.500, also mir fällt ja kaum was ein Multiplayer
technisch was so versagt hat, nur irgendwie 2,5 Monate nach Release oder sowas, also in
dieser Größenordnung, ja, es gibt natürlich Singleplayer Spiele, die kommen raus, sehen
so aus, 2, 3 Monate nach Release, aber große Multiplayer Titel selten, egal, also Wahnsinn.
Sie haben uns ja alle verarscht, ne, den Lost und mich ja auch am Anfang, wir haben den
Trailer gesehen, ihr könnt euch noch dran erinnern, wir sind voll ausgeflippt, wir haben
uns sogar zusammen gestreamt, irgendwie so 2, 3 Stunden, wo es das Trailer Reveal gab
und sind voll ausgeflippt, wie geil der Trailer ist, die haben uns alle jebaited und die haben
uns nicht nur jebaited, die haben uns ja Dinger gezeigt, die es nicht gibt in dem Spiel, also
die haben uns ja wirklich in die Irre geführt, von diesem komischen explosiven Buggy, bis,
boah, ich hab schon wieder die Hälfte vergessen, was da eigentlich gewesen ist, muss ich mir
nochmal angucken, hab ich jetzt aber auch keinen Bock, es gab 3, 4 Sachen, die waren
in diesem Trailer komplett falsch, gibt es gar nicht, so, aber wir haben witzigerweise
gesagt, es sieht geil aus, aber Leute, wie es sich spielt, könnte trotzdem kürze werden,
war es dann im Endeffekt auch, aber wir sind tatsächlich zu dem Zeitpunkt von ausgegangen,
es wird mega nice, das muss man ihnen aber auch echt lassen, also den Trailer haben sie
gut hingekriegt, leider haben sie da halt Sachen eingebaut, die es so nicht gibt in
dem Spiel, und danach ist halt für den Arsch gewesen, so, Voxmox Tools, nein, das muss
ich mir nicht angucken, dieser deutsche Maskenfilm ist cringe, ja, schön, Garage, Home Office,
Home Lab, so Videos guck ich mir immer gerne an, das können wir später gucken, wenn Leute
irgendwelche Kisten bauen, weiß ich, ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber mir gehen
Corona News komplett am Arsch vorbei mittlerweile, mich interessiert weder die Zahlen noch sonst
was, das einzige, wo ich mich für interessiere, ist, ob die Home Office Regel weiter gilt,
das ist mir egal, wegen mir kann Corona noch 5 Jahre gehen, wenn die Home Office Regel
und diese Home Office Pflichtregel, also die gesetzlich empolene, ich weiß gar nicht,
ob es eine Vorschrift ist, aufrechterhalten wird, Rest ist, Rest ist mir egal, was Mario
Kart Speedrunners break their controllers to set faster records, ja, ob das Cheating
ist, ist eine gute Frage, wenn man da irgendwas drauf überbrückt, dass man schneller drücken
kann und so ist es, Hardware mal nicht politisch, das ist auf jeden Fall Cheating, die sich
überlegen, ist ja, warum habe ich eigentlich die Musik ausgemacht, ah, weil ich Level Cap
Video eigentlich anmachen wollte, null, was am 20.
März ist Freedom Day, oh, ist das, ist das Korkona oder in Deutschland oder was, Freedom
Day hört sich, hört sich richtig, richtig krass nach Korkona an, Freedom Day, können
sich die Amis erst mal 20 Maschinengewehre kaufen, weil Freedom, in Deutschland, okay,
Freedom Day, kann man das nicht, kann man das nicht irgendwie auf Deutsch nennen, okay,
ich muss gerade was sagen, meine Sätze bestehen zu, wenn ich, wenn ich nicht drüber nachdenke
zu 90% aus wildem Deutsch, Englisch, Denglisch, Mischmasch und die ergeben doch nicht mal
viel Sinn, aber lustigerweise versteht der Chat trotzdem meistens, was ich meine, bis
auf manchmal, bis auf manchmal, es gibt ja manchmal so Sachen, da sage ich irgendwas
und denke mir so, das hat bestimmt keiner verstanden und dann frage ich den Chat und
der Chat sagt auch, das haben sie nicht verstanden, aber meistens funktioniert es, okay, alles
klar, okay, wir lassen uns mal von LevelCaptchi bilden jetzt, Moment, Moment, Moment, habe
ich das richtig verstanden, die Leute sind unhappy mit dem letzten Cyberpunk Patch, das
würde ja bedeuten, dass die mit irgendeinem zwischenzeitlichen Patch mal happy waren.
Oh ja, Audio, Audio müssen die unbedingt updaten, erinnert ihr euch noch daran, wo wir das hier
im Stream gespielt haben und das Audio, das hat sich angehört, als haben sie das bei
ihrer Mutter im, im, im, keine Ahnung, im Badezimmer aufgenommen, also das war wirklich
ganz, ganz grausam, Moment, Moment, erkenne ich das jetzt richtig, die sagen, die sagen,
das Audio-System wird überarbeitet und hoffen, die Leute freuen sich darüber, aber die
releasen kein Sample oder was, okay, das ist how to not hype, Leute, also wenn du was
Neues ankündigst, da solltest du es in gewisser Weise zumindest noch ein bisschen teasern,
das machen sie eigentlich alle mehr oder weniger, wenn die Leute gehypt sein sollen, immer
so ein bisschen was teasern noch und wenn du sagst, Audio-System, da solltest du vielleicht
mal ein Sample veröffentlichen, vorher, nachher oder sowas, weil ansonsten, naja, egal.
Ja, das ist das, wo sie erzählt haben, Halo Multiplayer war so erfolgreich in Battlefield,
ganz ehrlich, das ist die typische Geschichte, so nach dem Motto, ja, aber ich war es doch
nicht, wo sich irgendwelche Manager-Leute jetzt rausreden müssen und DICE erklären
muss, warum sie das Spiel so beschissen gemacht haben, ich meine, es ist ja nach wie vor,
das kann man glaube ich nicht oft genug sagen, weil die Leute sind nur, also ich hier am
Anfang auch, sind da so extrem auf EA fokussiert und natürlich hat EA sicherlich mit Deadlines
und Vorgaben und generell einem pausenlosen Richtungswechsel am Anfang dafür den Grundstein
gelegt, dass Battlefield 2042 beschissen geworden ist, aber DICE hat es am Ende zum
größten Teil mitverkackt, also man kann da nicht nur auf EA hauen, wenn ich in dem
Fall gewesen hätte, ich erstmal echt ne Runde Kack W müssen, stellt euch mal vor, ihr seid
Investor oder sonst wie oder intern irgendwie dafür zuständig, das irgendwie im Auge zu
behalten und euch, also ihr kennt euch ein bisschen, ihr habt die Spiele gespielt, was
wahrscheinlich an dem Fall nicht der Fall ist und sie versuchen euch ernsthaft zu erzählen,
Halo Infinite ist dafür verantwortlich, dass Battlefield 2042 so reingeschissen hat, dann
hätte ich den wirklich, dann hätte ich erstmal Facecam angemacht und hätte eine Runde Kack
W, dann hätte ich die Facecam wieder ausgemacht.
Und EA did in fact respond publicly to some degree, as EA Communications VP John Resenberg
stated that the narrative shade by Henderson's article doesn't accurately capture the full
discussion in context of the actual town hall meeting.
According to Resenberg, the EA meeting was less about blaming external factors like Halo
Infinite and more about sharing key learnings and how the company can push forward.
In terms of what is proposed for right now, EA and DICE have pushed back the launch of
Battlefield 2042's first season of content until early summer.
In the meantime, the development teams will work on the fundamental issues facing players
right now.
The next major update for the game, update 3.3, is set to launch next month.
It'll hopefully introduce basic features like VoIP, the scoreboard and fix other outstanding
bugs.
Das geht ja gar nicht mit dem Buggy, was man da gesehen hat.
Ganz ehrlich, das einzige was ich unfreiwillig mitbekommen habe, ich habe mir Cyberpunk nicht
gekauft.
Das hatte ich tatsächlich Glück, weil Cyberpunk vom Settings her überhaupt nicht meins ist,
ansonsten hätte ich es wahrscheinlich direkt bei Release gekauft.
Dementsprechend, nachdem das Spiel dann auch so beschissen war, habe ich nichts weiter
von mitbekommen.
Das einzige was ich unfreiwillig mitbekommen habe von Cyberpunk, ist Rule 34, und das ist
höchst verstörend bei Cyberpunk, ich empfehle euch nicht danach zu googeln.
Die Version bietet eine erarbeitete Perk-System, AI-Empfehlung, z.B.
Crowd- und Verkehrsveränderungen, eine reifere Fahrt-Experienz und sogar neue Gebäude
zu rentieren als Spieler.
Die Playstation 5 und Xbox-Series-Version des Spiels bietet eine viel schnellerere
Load-Zeit mit vielen technischen und visuellen Verbindungen.
Doch es ist nun eindeutig, dass nicht alles nach dem Plan gegangen ist.
Cyberpunk-Fans auf der Xbox-Series-S-Konsole sind enttäuscht, als das Spiel einen 60-Frame-Zwischen-Experienz
bietet, obwohl die visuelle Fidelity des Spiels erhebbar ist, dass die Framerate mehr
an viele Spieler wichtig ist.
Dieses Thema beeinflusst nicht die stärkere Playstation 5- oder Xbox-Series-X-Konsole,
die 4K 60 FPS möglich ist.
Sagt mal, Leute, es haben doch bestimmt ein paar von euch gespielt, ist das jetzt eigentlich
eher ein Open-World-Game oder ist das eher ein Story-Game mit rotem Faden?
Wo du aber dich sidetracken lassen konntest, ich vermute mal, dass das dort eh auch so
in der Richtung ist.
Ich meine, du konntest Witcher 3 theoretisch von Anfang bis Ende mit Main-Mission durchspielen,
dann hat das wenig Probleme, wenn du das machen willst.
Alternativ hast du halt dich links und rechts sidetracken lassen in der Open-World.
Also ich vermute mal, dass es da ähnlich ist.
Wie sieht es eigentlich mit dem Old-Gen-Release aus, ist das mit, das bekommt keine Patches
mehr, oder?
No Man's Sky, das muss man jetzt an der Stelle auch mal sagen, die haben es auch komplett
rumgedreht.
Und ich glaube, dass die gar nicht so extrem vorhatten, aus innerem Antrieb raus die Leute
zu scammen mit No Man's Sky.
Da hat Sony sicherlich auch eine tragende Rolle gespielt damals.
Die haben ja aus so einem kleinen Game, was halt so in Entwicklung ist, einen riesen Hype
gemacht damals.
Da war ja Sony nicht ganz unschuldig und der Typ, ich hab vergessen, wie er heißt, von
No Man's Sky, hat da halt mitgemacht.
Ich hab, wie ist der denn?
Keine Ahnung, wenn ich den Namen sehe, weiß ich es, Murray, das kann gut sein, der hat
ja damals mitgemacht.
Ihr könnt euch ja noch dran erinnern, diese Geschichte mit, ja es ist Multiplayer, aber
es ist die Chance so gering, dass man sich trifft, Game Launch, innerhalb der ersten
5 Stunden haben sich Leute getroffen und waren an der gleichen Stelle und haben sich nicht
gesehen und sowas.
Jaja, richtig krasser Chebat.
Aber die haben es ja wirklich 180 Grad herum gedreht, ja, also die haben nicht gesagt,
ok, wir haben das jetzt verkauft, wir cashen jetzt rein und verpissen uns, die, seit wann
ist das Game rausgekommen?
Vor 3 Jahren oder so oder noch länger, das ist ja schon eine ganze Weile, das gibt immer
noch Updates, also das ist, also da muss man wirklich sagen, Hut ab, das ist echt nicht
übel.
2016, also das ist schon 6 Jahre her.
Doch, das Internet Historien Video kennen wir, haben wir glaube ich geguckt, das heißt
irgendwie An Goodening of No Man's Sky oder so, das Internet Historien Video, das haben
wir geguckt.
Content dropped this week, the Sentinel update improves the game's combat systems, adds
new story missions, new AI, drone companions and much more.
Hello Games Founder Sean Murray shared that while the game has undergone plenty of changes
since its launch back in 2016, the team has far more to come.
Murray also shared that the team's energy is as high as...
Aber wisst ihr was ich cool finde, dass sich das immer noch anscheinend lohnt für die,
mit was?
Habt ihr eine Ahnung, mit was die No Man's Sky Leute Geld verdienen?
Das Game ist ja verkauft, gibt es da irgendwie Season Passes oder gibt es dort DLC Updates
oder buttert da einfach Sony dick Geld rein?
Wie verdienen die ihre Kohle?
Wir schauen uns jetzt an, wie es schon immer so war und dass sie sich gespannt sind, das
Spiel weiter zu unterstützen.
Hey Low Infinite, wir sehen einige große Veränderungen zum Competitive Skill Ranking System.
In einer Blog-Post haben 343 Industries ihre Pläne ausgetauscht, um Probleme mit
Spieler-Rank-Inflation, unerwünschte Skill-Assessungen und unerwünschte Spieler-Skills zu verhindern.
Probleme, die das Spiel schon seit dem Launchen effizient sind.
343 hat auch gesagt, dass Veränderungen zum Competitive Skill Ranking System wie dieses
werden sich während des Spiels verhindern und dass Spieler noch mehr Veränderungen
auf die Linie erwarten sollten.
Das alte System war überlegentlich und das neue System sollte hoffentlich die Dinge
näher in die Linie bringen, wo sie sein sollten.
Der Reset in die Stats wird...
Oh nein!
Ich werde meinen Rang dropen!
Das bedeutet, dass Spieler sich einen vollen Tieren unten finden, wo sie aktuell sind.
In anderen Halo-News sind Leak-Details des hochartigen Forge-Modes geschehen.
Das Forge-Mode wird nicht bis zum 2.
Multiplayer-Saison im Mai offiziell veröffentlicht.
Ja, das finde ich ist auch eine...
Also man...
Halo Infinite hat genug eigene Probleme, ich weiß gar nicht, warum die das als Grund
anführen, dass Battlefield gefehlt ist.
Ich meine, gerade viele Halo-Fans sind wirklich pissed, dass Forge nicht drinne ist von Release.
Placing different objects around their own custom map.
Objects like vehicles, player characters and static walls.
Forge will apparently even offer the ability to change the map biomes and day night cycle.
Many fans wonder if you'll be able to place enemy AI-Characters into your own custom
world, resulting in endless potential.
Giving players the freedom to create their own campaigns or multiplayer maps could see
Halo Infinite build a very long-term community.
An update released to Windows 11 Insiders this week has given gamers...
Ja, das Schlimmste ist an diesem Update, dass es einen Microsoft-Account-Zwang hat.
...a lot to look forward to.
Microsoft is promising to significantly improve latency while playing games in windowed mode.
They're working to implement variable refresh rates to individual windowed programs too,
which is usually something controlled by drivers and strictly reserved for full-screen applications.
Similarly, this Insider build of Windows 11...
Ja, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Und gerade wenn's in Windowed Mode ist, muss das ja eh alles Composite-managert werden
von DWM.
Da kannst du natürlich ne Anwendung rendern lassen mit 300 FPS und eine andere mit 20
FPS, kein Ding.
Ja, mach schon.
...also features the drag-and-drop taskbar functionality that has been absent from the
new operating system since it launched last October.
There's no specific timeline as to when these features will make it to the public build
of Windows 11, but enthusiasts reckon that it won't take too long.
DAs, Star Wars The Old Republic's Legacy of the Sith expansion released during the
week, and after a stellar cinematic short film, fans' expectations were at an all-time
high.
Ja, mittlerweile ist es ja wirklich schon standard, dass die Cinematics besser sind als das,
was man dann am Ende als Game bekommt.
The reviews for the game on Steam did see an upswing in positive reviews, the official
forums and social channels share a different narrative.
According to fans, the story itself is far too short and the update has introduced plenty
of significant bugs.
The UI changes aren't to everyone's taste, the new combat styles could be seen as down
grays and the changes to classes haven't pleased fans either.
Some bugs seem like minor inconveniences, where some could be pretty detrimental to the gameplay.
Overall...
Oh nein!
Ein Game, das verbuggt rauskommt?
Damit hätten wir doch jetzt nicht gerechnet, oder?
Fans have critiqued the size of the update, claiming that it shouldn't really be considered
an expansion at all.
Patch 17 for the Popular Tactical World War II FP...
Leute, lohnt sich das?
Ich wollt mir das schon bestimmt die letzten zwei Jahre mal angucken.
Spielt das einer von euch, lohnt sich das?
Hell Let Loose, lohnt sich das?
Gerade bei Games, die ne Weile brauchen, bis sie so zünden im Endeffekt, und ich glaub,
das ist das, eins weiß ich immer nicht, ob es sich lohnt, damit noch anzufangen, wenn
die Games schon so ewig draußen sind.
PS Game Hell Let Loose ist still being worked on by the development teams at Black Matter,
the art team has been working on multiple fronts for Hell Let Loose content, but has
also had a chance to revisit existing content and assets.
By working on current content, the team is able to better optimize the game's assets,
resulting in better performance overall.
As an example, Black Matter shared their revised FG42, showing off the new smart materials that
give the weapon a much more detailed appearance without impacting the game's performance.
This method of applying smart materials is also being applied to Soldier Uniforms, vehicles
and other weapons, resulting in a more refined game with better performance.
As time goes on, the devs will gradually replace old assets with new ones, such as the German
Panther Tank, which will return in Update 12.
Open World Adventure Game Horizon Forbidden West launched two rave reviews from critics
and players.
It's a direct sequel to 2017's Horizon Zero Dawn.
The original game was a smash hit and considered a technical marvel on the PlayStation 4 Pro.
Forbidden West ups the ante with seriously enhanced visuals and an even more expansive
open world.
And while some reviews express concern that the increased scale of the game muddies its
storytelling, the general conclusion is that it's still a solid experience overall that
improves the original.
The one big question mark is when will Forbidden West launch on PC?
The PlayStation 5 version of the game is a pretty close approximation to what's possible
on PC, and Zero Dawn was a massive success for Sony on PC.
You might even go as far as to say that the game's success on PC kickstarted Sony's
PC porting initiative.
They recently launched God of War on PC and it sold like wildfire.
Hopefully Sony doesn't string us along for another three years like they did with Zero
Dawn.
So, wie sieht's eigentlich aus mit dem neuen God of War, das haben die ja schon vor
so sah, und
PC-Klose-Playtest-Nächsten-Monat, ein Detail, das viele dedikierte Fans direkt hinbekommen haben.
Sharkmob hat offiziell im nächsten Monat die Playtesten auf ihren Haupt-Social-Kanälen
dieses Wochenjahr entdeckt, die Spieler-Suspitionen.
Die Playtest-Nächsten-Monat wird für alle, die vorher einen Sharkmob-Account kreierten und
noch in gutem Zustand sind.
Das Fokus-Aere...
Ein was für ein Account?
Ein Sharkmob-Account?
Okay, man braucht wieder irgendwie für irgendeinen Service mal wieder einen neuen Account,
alles klar.
Die Playtest wird die Spiel-Performance und die visuelle Qualität sein.
Die Playtest wird für zwei Tage laufen, mit den exakten Daten und Zeitungen, die näher
zu dem Event werden.
Die Entwickler ermöglichen die Spieler, das Spiel auf DirectX 12 zu runnen,
denn es sollte besser laufen.
Jedoch, stetteren und minderen Performance-Bugs sind noch zu erwarten.
Bloodhunt ist bereit, zu vollen Launchen dieses Jahr.
Ich war ja zu einer Zeit noch etwas jünger, wo dieser ganze Vampir-Hype voll angesagt war.
Ging auch komplett an mir vorbei.
Was juckt dich nicht, das Game?
Ja, okay, das Video ist fertig, nice.
GG Eats.
Oh, was haben wir hier?
Hey Max, ich wurde die Nacht Opfer von einem Phishing-Hacker auf Discord.
Und dieser hat meinen Account nun in Beschlag.
Er hat sofort das Passwort geändert und scheinbar die Auth-Methode.
Kann das Passwort nicht sogar, wenn ich jetzt alle Verknüpfungen vom Account gelöscht habe,
die, äh, was?
Und hab den Account, wo ich selber Mail-Passwort nutze geändert.
Ja, das ist gut.
Ich würde allerdings auch generell meine Passwörter mehr ändern.
Selbst wenn du das gleiche Passwort hast woanders.
Hast du noch Tipps, was kann er gegebenenfalls noch machen?
Äh, ja, ich würde den Support anschreiben.
Ja, tatsächlich, das wäre das Einzige, was du machen kannst.
Und ich weiß nicht, wie Discord damit umgeht.
Also ob du dich irgendwie dann ausweisen musst oder keine Ahnung.
Ansonsten bleibt dir da nicht viel übrig, als die Sachen zu entfernen.
Würde ich jetzt nicht.
Wie hast du dich denn überhaupt fischen lassen mit Zwei-Faktor-Ordinifizierung?
Oder interpretiere ich hier Zwei-Faktor-Ordinifizierung nur rein?
Oder war nur ein normales Passwort-E-Mail.
Oder geht das natürlich deutlich einfacher.
Ja gut, du kannst einen neuen Account machen, aber das ist ja nicht, was er machen will.
Er will ja seinen alten Account wieder haben.
Und er hat Angst, dass derjenige, der den Account jetzt hat, damit...
Wie wird der Amthor jetzt sagen? Schabernack treibt.
Ja, zum Beispiel kannst du ja, wenn du einen Discord-Account hast, der Leute geadded hat, kannst du dich ja dann als der Besitzer ausgeben.
Und denen vielleicht weiteres Zeugs unterschieben und sowas.
Achso, ja, das kann immer mal passieren, ja.
Beats Batman.
Deswegen, Leute, ihr wisst ja immer, hier, ne.
Er hat Nitro wieder abgeschlossen.
Der hat wahrscheinlich Nitro abgeschlossen.
Nicht über dein Payment, sondern wahrscheinlich über anderes geklautes Payment oder so.
Das ist auch geil. Stell dir vor, du klaust einen Discord-Account und kaufst erst mal Nitro dafür.
Das wär's, ey. Wenn er es dann auch noch mit seinem eigenen Geld bezahlt hätte. Lul.
Das wär geil. Das wär richtig dämlich.
Die Mail hat er nicht geändert. Ja, ich glaube, die Mail kannst du bei Discord gar nicht so einfach ändern.
Wenn du nicht Zugriff auf die ursprüngliche E-Mail-Adresse hast, oder?
Was will man mit einem Discount-Account? Tja, das kann man sich bei 99% der Skriptleute so fragen.
Keine Ahnung, was sie damit wollen.
Kein Schimmer.
Vielleicht gibt es die Möglichkeit zu sagen, du hast den Zugriff auf deinen Authenticator verloren.
Ah, hat Discord nicht auch sowas, dass wenn man zwei Faktor-Authentifizierungen einschaltet,
dass man sich so 10 Codes generieren lassen kann?
Ach, die Backup-Codes hat er zurückgesetzt. Ja.
Dann, äh, keine Ahnung, dann muss man wahrscheinlich echt auf Discord-Support warten.
Keine Ahnung. Das Problem hatte ich zum Glück noch nicht.
Es hat nur mal einer in meinem O-Account von mir gehackermant.
Da wurde ich dann gebannt. Temp-Band wurde ich.
Weil ich Leute angeblich ingame beleidigt habe und das war ich nicht.
Da war ich aber blöd, da habe ich meinen Account auch weitergegeben an jemand anderen.
Und der hat es nicht ausgenutzt. Das war okay, aber der selbst hat sich irgendeinen Scheiß auf seinem Rechner eingefangen mit Keylogger und sonst was.
Also, das ist eh was. Wenn man Accounts weitergibt, geht es nicht nur darum, traut man demjenigen, dem man den Account weitergibt,
sondern traut man auch den technischen Fähigkeiten desjenigen, an dem man den Account weitergibt,
sich keine Keyloggers oder sonstigen Shit einzufangen.
Ich habe echt doof geguckt, als ich gebannt wurde.
Ich habe gesagt, hä, wie, ich habe Leute beleidigt in-game, ich war noch gar nicht eingeloggt.
Da, bäm, ja. Scheiße was.
Und den Support damals konntest du vergessen.
Kann er über die Webseite, wo ich drauf war, irgendwelche Software auf meinem PC gemacht haben?
Naja, also die theoretische Möglichkeit besteht natürlich immer, dass irgendwie einer irgendwelche Lücken im Browser ausnutzt oder sonst wie.
Aber die Wahrscheinlichkeiten sind aktuell, würde ich sagen, relativ gering.
Also, irgendwelche Chrome Zero Days oder sonstige Geschichten.
Also, für das, dass der Browser eigentlich das Hauptangriffsziel schlechthin sein müsste heutzutage, halten die Dinge erstaunlich gut.
Also, ich würde sagen, du hast dir wahrscheinlich nichts eingefangen, wenn du die Sachen runtergeladen hast von der Webseite.
Wenn du die Sachen runtergeladen hast von der Webseite und angeklickt hast, gut, dann ist ja logisch.
Aber einfach nur auf der Webseite zu sein mit einem aktuellen Browser, am besten, wenn du da noch sowas wie uBlock oder sowas an hast.
Möglich, aber wahrscheinlich nicht.
Eher unwahrscheinlich.
So, was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Shocking State of JavaScript, wie es die coolen Leute sagen.
Es gibt übrigens neues Battlefield Friends.
Habt ihr mitgekriegt, dass es neue Battlefield Friends gibt?
Ich habe immer gedacht, er wiederholt nur die alten und hat keinen Bock, neue zu machen, weil das Game so gesagt hat.
Aber spätestens, wenn du die Kiste neu installiert hast, dann ist eh vorbei.
Ich meine, natürlich gibt es immer irgendwelche theoretischen Szenarien, aber ist ja relativ unwahrscheinlich.
Was ist Battlefield Friends? Das war eine Serie zu Battlefield 3 und 4 Zeiten.
So eine Comic-Style-Serie über Battlefield-In-Game-Ereignisse.
Sowas, was ich von Chopper Gunner bis Lag bis sonst was, die sich über Sachen in Battlefield lustig gemacht haben.
Und der Veteran war eh der beste.
Erinnert sich noch einer an den Battlefield Friends Veteran?
An den Level 100, an den Colonel 100 Typ, der alles gemessert hat, sogar Helis gemessert hat.
Battlefield Friends war der beste, ja, war richtig nice.
Colonel 100, der war ein geiler Typ.
Das verdient ein Lehrer an der Realschule.
Wahrscheinlich, ich predikte das jetzt mal, wahrscheinlich nicht genug.
Für den Scheiß, ganz ehrlich, ich würde im Leben, also ich wüsste nicht, was mir jemand bieten müsste.
Dass ich freiwillig das machen würde, was Lehrer machen.
Also ich kann eh Kinder und Jugendliche schon nicht ab.
Aber ich kann eigentlich niemand ab.
Das war genau nichts.
Aber das mir jeden Tag zu geben, nee, wirklich nicht.
Das letzte Video ist über Twitch-Streamer.
Echt, zeig mal her, was verdient ein Twitch-Streamer?
Was verdient ein Streamer?
Okay, das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Wer ist das, wen zeigen sie da?
Wer ist das?
Zeig mal her, kenn ich den?
Nee.
Was hat er oft verbaut?
Ah, LOL-Streamer, okay.
Kein Wunder, LOL ist ja überhaupt nicht so meins.
Okay, das schauen wir uns mal an.
Das gucken wir uns mal an.
Was verdient ein Streamer?
Kann ich auch mal einen Senf dazu abgeben.
Nicht unbedingt als Streamer, aber als Streamer-Youtube-Content-Creator, der das schon über 10 Jahre macht.
So, schauen wir mal.
Wow, ich sitze am Computer und spiele Spiele.
Das macht mir Spaß und damit kann ich auch noch Geld verdienen.
Hört sich doch gut an.
Das habe ich mir auch gedacht am Anfang.
Genau das habe ich mir auch gedacht.
Ja, ganz so ist es dann leider doch nicht.
Je mehr Reizweite ein Content-Creator hat, desto mehr Geld kriegt er auch.
Wisst ihr was mich bei diesen Beiträgen immer nervt, dass die Musik viel lauter ist als die Sprache?
Wenn ich keine Zuschauer habe, kriege ich null Euro.
Okay, schauen wir uns das mal an.
Das sind unsere jungen und hauptberufliche Streamer.
Jetzt haben wir es 7.45 Uhr.
Ich würde jetzt gleich sofort den Stream anmachen.
Kamera muss natürlich immer laufen.
Hier auf dem Bildschirm habe ich mein Stream-Programm.
Damit ich sehe, was die gerade sehen, die Zuschauer.
7.45 Uhr?
Alter, da will es aber wissen.
7.55 Uhr denke ich vielleicht gerade mal Betke zu beenden.
Dass ich hier eine Benachrichtigung bekomme, wer folgt, wer hat donate.
Hier ist dann mein Spiel.
Ja, da sieht man, so machen das professionelle Streamer.
Nicht so wie ich, der immer alle möglichen Subs und Follower und Content übersieht.
Und das, obwohl ich einen zweiten Monitor auf habe.
Aber ich habe eigentlich nur den Chat und meinen Imageboard auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Sonst nichts.
Naja.
Der hat Streamlabs, ja.
Offensichtlich hat er Streamlabs.
So, Loll am Start.
Dann geht es auch schon los in 3,2,1.
Alter, aber 7.45 Uhr.
Nicht schlecht.
Also da geht es los.
Das ist wirklich hier 8 Stunden Job.
Und wir sind live.
Meistens, wir sehen das hier schon um 7.40 Uhr, sind schon Leute da, die dann warten.
Und da ist Darkflip.
Schön, dass du da bist.
Der normale Ablauf von meinem Stream ist so, dass ich am Anfang...
Das muss ich ja sagen, das finde ich auch immer nice.
Das finde ich wirklich cool.
Und das ist auch was, was ich an Twitch geil finde.
Sobald du den Stream anmachst, du hast so ein paar Leute, die sind fast immer irgendwie am Start.
Der Phipps zum Beispiel ist hier immer am Start.
Ich glaube, der pennt aktuell noch.
Aber normalerweise bei späteren Streams hast du Leute, die sind immer am Start.
Und die schon den Tab offen und warten nur drauf.
Das ist wirklich nice.
Wir haben zusammen Spiele, um warm zu werden, um wach zu werden.
Okay, guten Morgen, BG, guten Morgen, Vranu, Aurora, Meiste, Joghurt, RF, Joker, Giovanni, Forever, Rekupfer, Dechle.
Grüßt euch. Schön, dass ihr da seid.
Viele Leute spielen selber das Spiel nebenbei.
Und haben dann noch auf einem anderen Monitor auch nochmal jetzt mein Stream oder auch einen anderen Stream auf.
Oder ein YouTube-Video, eine Doku.
Viele Leute lassen sich davon berieseln.
Also die wenigsten sitzen wirklich Hauptmonitor da vorne, meinen Stream da drauf.
Und sind die ganze Zeit im Chat und schreiben dann was rein.
Das machen die wenigsten.
Kommt halt auf den Stream, kommt auf das Game an.
Ich glaube, das ist bei den meisten der Fall sowohl bei YouTube als auch auf Twitch.
Das ist was, was du nebenbei laufen lässt.
Und wenn irgendwas Spannendes passiert, guckst du auch mal.
Die einzige Zeit, wo ich wirklich richtig aktiv g'watched habe auf Twitch,
also wo ich auch mir echt genau angeguckt hab, was die Leute machen,
war, wo ich Overwatch gespielt habe, versucht hab auch ganz gut zu spielen.
Da hab ich mir die üblichen Verdächtigen angeguckt,
die quasi so mehr oder weniger den gleichen Heldenpool hatten wie ich.
Und dann hab ich mir, also die guten Leute, hab ich mir genau angeschaut, was die so machen.
Aber ansonsten guck ich eigentlich eher auch so nebenbei.
Bei Pool-Streams.
Ja Leute, die Pool-Streams gucken, die gucken die sich wahrscheinlich wirklich genau an.
Da haste wohl recht.
Nessi, guten Morgen, Jascha.
Grüßt euch schon, dass ihr da seid.
Und viel Spaß in der Schule, Nessi.
In der Schule?
Gut aufpassen, ne?
Die sind schon mal im Stream, bevor die Schule losgeht.
Heiß.
Wichtig. Und Hausaufgaben machen.
Jetzt muss ich natürlich auch in den Game-Stream abliefern.
Oh, ich bin ein bisschen spät dran. Und ich bin schon wieder tot.
Nein.
Nach einer Stunde hab ich meistens so 400.
Er ist schon wieder tot.
Das heißt, he doesn't know he lacks critical information, oder was?
Würde ich sagen.
Und dann nach zwei, drei Stunden so Richtung 6, 700.
Und dann, wenn wir so 12, 11 Uhr haben, hab ich dann so...
Das ist so ein Ding.
Das ist mir auch schon aufgefallen.
Also man profitiert auf...
Also ja, es schwankt über die Tageszeit schon.
Das ist so.
Also was weiß ich, wenn ich nachmittags anfange, wenn es dann so Richtung Abendessen geht,
dann troppt es manchmal ein bisschen runter und so.
Oder auch zwischendurch, wenn die Leute daheim fahren oder was auch immer.
Zumindest eins hab ich auch schon gemerkt.
Es lohnt sich auf Twitch unglaublich, wenn man einfach oft lang online ist.
Weil eben Leute hängen bleiben.
Was dir permanente Zuschauer bringt.
Weil viele finden so cool, die schalten das nächste Mal auch wieder ein.
Und du sammelst die quasi auch ein.
Die bleiben dann einfach bei dir hängen.
Und vielleicht auch nur für den Tag oder so.
Aber gut, die Chance, dass die da bleiben, ist natürlich auch gegeben.
Du sammelst die quasi ein.
Und die bleiben dann...
Deswegen ist es auch immer so dumm, wenn das Stream abkackt zwischendurch.
Mal für 3-4 Minuten.
Weil Vodafone oder so wieder rumspackt.
Du sammelst die ein.
Und du hast dann tatsächlich zunehmend mehr, wenn du lange on bist.
Und vor allem auch wenn du oft on bist.
Die Sache ist plus die.
Ich krieg das nicht gebacken.
Leute, wenn ich mal 3 oder maximal 4 Stunden on bin,
dann bin ich schon immer so im Arsch.
5 Stunden.
Also würde ich überhaupt nicht gebacken bekommen.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie die das alle machen.
Gibt ja Leute, die streamen fast täglich 8 Stunden oder so.
Wenn ich mir den Lost angucke, der Lost ist glaube ich fast 5 Tage oder so da.
Und streamt dann irgendwie 7-11 Stunden.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die das machen.
Ich hab echt keinen Schimmer, wie die das aushalten.
Wenn es gut läuft, 900, 800 bis 1000, irgendwo so da in der Range.
Und dann hält sich das eine Zeit.
Und dann baut es am Ende wieder langsam ab.
So das ist meistens der Verlauf.
Aber Zuschauer natürlich, das ist ganz schlimm.
Da werden viele Streamer auch krank von, von den Zuschauern.
Weil die sich da sehr abhängig sind.
Ihr seid dran schuld, wenn ich krank bin.
Jetzt wusste ich schon immer.
In Wirklichkeit ist der Chat dran schuld.
Der Chat ist ja prinzipiell immer an allem schuld.
Und ich zum Teil auch.
Wobei man sagen muss, mein Chat nicht.
Mein Chat hat ja schon einen äußerst hohen Anteil High IQ, Leute.
Ich bin schon permanent am Trinken.
Das Gehusste ist wirklich nervig.
Leute, soll ich euch mal sagen, ich glaube ich weiß woran das liegt.
Ihr habt es ja mitgekriegt.
Das muss ich jetzt mal an der Stelle kurz loswerden.
Ich bin ja eigentlich schon die letzten paar Monate relativ oft am Husten.
Wahrscheinlich ist es dem einen oder anderen aufgefallen.
Und ich glaube ich weiß jetzt woran das liegt.
Ich glaube ich habe Sodbrennen.
Das ist mir vor zwei Tagen aufgefallen.
Und genau davon kriegst du sowas.
Du kriegst sowas natürlich auch durch irgendwelche Atemwegseffekte oder sonst was.
Oder durch Rauchen oder durch Trinken oder durch sonst was, klar.
Aber ich habe auch mal ein bisschen im Internet herumgeguckt.
Ich rauche nicht und ich saufe nichts.
Sodbrennen ist tatsächlich eines der Auslöser für so Reizhusten schlechthin.
Wusste ich nicht.
Und ja gut, was soll ich jetzt dagegen machen?
Ich werde...
Also wenn ich jetzt irgendwie zu einem Arzt gehe, der sagt hier nehmen sie irgendwie Zeug da.
Blocker, Magensäure, Zeug aus der Apotheke.
Kein Bock drauf das dauerhaft zu nehmen.
Auf irgendeine Magenspielung habe ich halt auch keinen Bock.
Nur wobei ich halt, wenn ich mir nicht mehr so nachdenke, das ist auch so.
Also ich merke das.
Gerade nachts wenn ich liege, dann merke ich, dass es gerade hier hinten im Hals hoch,
also Speiseröhre bis zum Kehlkopf hoch, dass es dann brennt.
Es ist nicht so dieses ultrakrasse Sodbrennen wie es manche beschreiben.
So nach dem Motto, dass sie denken sie haben Herzinfarkt oder sowas.
Aber ich merke das.
Und da habe ich nie was drauf gegeben, habe ich mal gedacht, ja gut, macht ja nichts.
Tut nicht ultra weh, ist nur ab und zu mal...
Hast du häufiger nach bestimmten Essen auch quasi Durchfall, muss sehr schnell aufs Klo?
Ja, wobei das relativ random ist, weil das relativ random ist.
Ja, also wie gesagt, ich glaube wirklich jetzt habe ich echt Sodbrennen.
Und jetzt kommt ärztliche Beratung vorm Twitch Chat.
Das wäre es hier noch.
Ich meine es gab Twitch Plays Pokemon, warum soll es nicht eben Twitch Plays Doktor?
Nee, aber wenn das nicht besser wird, ich versuche jetzt mal ein bisschen mehr Kartoffelstärke,
halte ich als Zeug und mehr zu trinken und sowas.
Kaffee trinke ich ja aus Prinzip, habe ich noch nie großartig getrunken.
Und Essig ist schon mal ganz schlecht für Sodbrennen.
So, und wenn es nicht besser wird, muss ich Wohle oder Übel wirklich mal untersuchen lassen.
Man sollte mal, ja es sollte tatsächlich Sprechstunden über Twitch geben.
Egal, wir gucken jetzt erstmal das Video fertig.
Nur mal so eingeworfen, es ist mir vor zwei Tagen eingefallen, ich habe zufällig was
gelesen dazu, da habe ich mir gedacht, Moment mal, das ist doch im Prinzip genau das, das
ist exakt das, was sie dort beschrieben haben.
Von Husten bis Heißerkeit teilweise, bis Jucken im Hals, so dieses ganze Zeug, wo du normalerweise
ein bisschen denkst an irgendwelche Erkältungen oder so.
Vor allem wenn es immer wieder geht, das war richtig, das war exakt das, was ich auch alles
habe, was in diesem Artikel drin stand.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, okay, ich merke das ja auch nachts teilweise im Hals hoch,
das wahrscheinlich habe ich echt so drin.
Das wäre, ich habe es zwar schon lange gemerkt, aber nie wirklich dran gedacht.
Egal, wir gucken jetzt das Video erstmal fertig.
Er spielt fast ausschließlich Loll.
Ja, mein Loll ist echt ein Game, muss man sagen.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass MOBAs, also so 2012 oder so, wann das alles angefangen
hat, oder 2000.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, als ich in die Berufsschule gegangen bin noch, 2009
oder so, haben die Leute mir schon teilweise erzählt, was sie für krasse Skillshots gemacht
haben.
Ich glaube, die haben Loll gespielt.
Wann kam denn Loll raus?
Ja, 2009, okay, es kann sein.
Und ich hätte nie gedacht, da habe ich auch ein bisschen falsch gelegen, dass Loll so
lange der Dauerbrenner sein wird.
Mein Loll ist doch jetzt schon auf, keine Ahnung, Jahrzehnte quasi schon führend auf
Twitch.
Also, das hätte ich am Anfang nicht gedacht.
MOBAs an sich sind eigentlich wieder ein bisschen in der Versenkung verschwunden.
Klar, du hast Dota noch.
Du hast Loll.
Du hast ab und zu mal ein bisschen Heroes of the Storm, aber du hast hauptsächlich Loll
und ein bisschen Dota.
Diese ganzen Sachen, wir machen alle unser eigenes, MOBA ist vorbei.
Aber Loll hat sich gehalten und Loll hält sich auch weiter und Loll wird sich wahrscheinlich
auch weiterhalten.
Das hätte ich am Anfang nicht gedacht, aber das spricht ja durchaus auch für die Qualitäten
des Games.
Obwohl ich die nicht einschätzen kann, weil ich keinen Plan von MOBAs habe und Loll noch
nie gespielt habe, aber es spricht ja für das Game und es spricht auch für Riot mit
dem Umgang des Games, dass die wohl was richtig machen.
Also League of Legends ist ein 5 gegen 5 Echtzeit Strategiespiel.
Das Hauptziel ist, das Hauptgebäude zu zerstören.
Jedes Team hat ein Hauptgebäude, aber das Hauptgebäude steht nicht einfach so.
Das Hauptgebäude ist der Nexus, das weiß ich.
Das glaube ich das Einzige, was ich weiß, über Loll.
Das wird von Türmen beschützt und dann von den Spielern natürlich und man muss dieses
Hauptgebäude...
Und der Turm vor dem Hauptgebäude heißt Inheritor, Inhibitor oder irgendwie sowas.
Ihr müsst mir das jetzt sagen, ob ich recht habe oder nicht, weil ich habe keine Ahnung
von Loll.
Das habe ich nur immer mal so aufgeschnappt, links und rechts.
Ich würde es nicht reichen, Just for fun zu spielen, sondern bei mir ist es wirklich
der Hang zur Competition.
Also ich möchte gut sein in dem Spiel, ich möchte extrem gut werden.
Wenn du es mal wortwörtlich nimmst, was ist ein Pro Gamer?
Ein Pro Gamer ist nicht unbedingt Leute, die einfach nur gut in dem Spiel sind.
Das wird ja oftmals so mit gleichgesetzt, wenn man es genauer nimmt, sind Pro Gamer
Leute, die mit dem, dass sie spielen, quasi Geld verdienen können oder halt noch besser
gesagt ihren Lebensunterhalt verdienen.
Dementsprechend sind Streamer, auch wenn die Streamer nicht auf Turnieren erster Platz
werden, sind Streamer Pro Gamer, wenn man es so will.
Und natürlich musst du dafür gut sein.
Ich glaube, es guckt keiner jemand gerne so einem Game zu, der einfach die ganze Zeit
verreckt.
Einer der besten vielleicht sogar und das macht mir dann Spaß zu Climben auch.
Ich habe 454 Zuschauer gerade.
Um 8.14 Uhr.
Da bin ich gerade aufgestanden.
Der will es wissen.
Da wird gehaschelt.
Oder?
Ich muss aufhören mit diesen dämlichen Dingern.
Auf dem Weg auf den Mount Everest.
Bei meiner Mutter gelebt habe, die hat mich durchgehend supportet.
Und mein Vater war da eher die Person, die gesagt hat, Phil, mach doch mal was
Richtiges.
Jetzt ist es so, dass sich mein Dad immer mehr mit dem Thema auseinandersetzt.
Also jetzt schaut er mal auf Twitter, mal auf Twitch.
Was geht da?
Davor war ich natürlich noch abhängig von meinen Eltern.
Und dann haben die da ja irgendwo auch Mitsprache.
Hat man gesehen, wie alt er ist?
Ich würde jetzt so um die 20 schätzen, aber kann man schwer sagen.
Wie ich diese Zeit, wo sie mich unterstützen und ich nur durch diese Unterstützung über
die Runden komme, was ich mit der Zeit mache und wie lange das dann eventuell noch geht.
Weil mein Vater hat gedacht, okay, wenn der jetzt weiter am PC hockt, dann muss ich den
noch die nächsten zehn Jahre durchführen.
Das denken aber alle Eltern, die keine Ahnung haben von dieser Geschichte, was die
meisten sind.
Natürlich denken die das.
Meine Eltern haben ja damals auch gedacht so nach dem Motto, wenn der jetzt nicht mal
endlich anfängt, eine Ausbildung zu machen, dann wird das nichts.
Tja, ist ja auch verständlich.
Ich meine, das ist eine andere Welt und die kennen sich da nicht so aus.
Also er steht da jetzt so gesehen auch hinter mir.
Aber der Support, den ich mir da gewünscht hätte, kam da nicht leider.
Und jetzt kommt direkt die Transition ins Ränket.
Und dafür fahre ich mal den Tisch hoch.
Also nicht zum Spielen, sondern dass ich einfach in den Pausen, während ich nicht spiele,
dass ich in den Pausen stehe.
Hey, ich glaube, der hat exakt das gleiche Gestell wie ich.
Das sieht original so aus.
Von den Beinen her am Tisch.
Poggers.
Höhenverstellbare Tisch, Leute, ich sage euch, beste, beste.
Kabelsalat, ja, das muss so sein.
Warum soll man das ordentlich machen?
Höhenverstellbarer Schreibtisch, bester.
Wie oft fährst du deinen Tisch nach oben?
Ratet mal.
Null.
Naja, nee, nee, nee.
Also wenn es hochkommt, so einmal alle zwei Tage oder so.
Das ist unnötig.
Nein, das ist nicht unnötig.
Also an sich ist ein höhenverstellbarer Tisch mit das Geilste, was es gibt.
Also das Wichtigste ist erst mal einen Stuhl mit Armlehnen zu haben.
Aber danach kommt ein höhenverstellbarer Tisch.
Das ist mega geil.
Ich bin einfach nur zu faul.
Ansonsten ist das eigentlich das Beste, was es gibt.
Setup kann ich gerne zeigen, ist relativ simpel eigentlich.
Also wir haben hier Mikrofon plus Mikrofonarm,
damit die Leute mich im Stream hören.
Dann haben wir hier obviously drei Bildschirme.
Dann haben wir die Kamera, die das Bild in den Stream überträgt.
Und ansonsten Maustastatur, Mauspad brauche ich noch.
Kopfhörer.
Das ist der PC.
Was hat er denn für einen...
Haben wir das irgendwo gesehen, was er für einen...
Das könnte ein Bayer Dynamics sein, oder?
Nee, da steht sein Name drauf.
Also von der Optik her muss ich sagen, es sieht verdächtig.
Es sieht verdächtig nach einem MMX300 aus.
Ja?
Also es sieht verdächtig nach einem MMX300 aus.
Auch hier unten das...
Krass, dem MMX300, okay?
Und jetzt habe ich nicht geguckt, wo wir stehen geblieben, hier irgendwo.
Was hast du? Ich habe auch einen MMX300 gerade auf.
Ich weiß, ich sollte eigentlich lieber über mein normales Mikrofon streamen,
sondern einfach weil die Qualität besser ist und es nicht so bloppt
und es nicht so rauscht, nicht so reibt am Hemd und so was teilweise.
Aber gerade für irgendwelche Aufwachstreams, ich bin einfach zu faul.
Da habe ich lieber ein Headset an, das ist bequemer.
Das MMX300 hat ein halbwegs gutes Mikrofon, ja.
Im Vergleich zu irgendwelchen billigen anderen Headset Mikrofonen ist das schon ganz gut,
aber trotzdem ist sowas hier immer noch besser.
Na ja, weil du sonst viel zu sehr deine Arme und Schultern und so was den ganzen Tag anspannen musst,
nur um die Hände oben zu halten.
Ich meine, manche haben natürlich auch ihren riesen Schreibtisch
und haben das so weit vorne, dass sie quasi vorgebeugt sitzen können
und einen kompletten Arm und so auf dem Schreibtisch haben können.
Wobei ich dann frage, ob die Haltung ganz taugt, ehrlich gesagt,
weil du musst dich ja schon, also du musst dich ja schon,
so soll man 20-30% vorbeugen, dass deine Ellenbogen auf dem Tisch sind.
Tja, Geschmackssache.
Aber ich finde, ein Tisch mit, also ein hilferstellbarer Tisch
und einen Stuhl mit Armlehnen ist eigentlich das Wichtigste überhaupt.
Die Kamera, die das Bild in den Stream überträgt
und ansonsten Maustastatur, Mauspad brauche ich noch.
Kopfhörer, das ist der PC.
Okay, es ist nicht der gleiche Tisch, aber es sieht sehr ähnlich aus.
Von meinem alten Sponsor Hightech, dementsprechend habe ich den nicht bezahlt
und der hätte mindestens 3000 Euro Richtung...
Na ja, heutzutage hätte er wahrscheinlich 5000 Euro gekostet,
weil da aktuelle Grafikkarte drin ist und die kostet alleine ja schon 2K.
Und 4000 Euro, würde ich sagen.
Eine Stunde Live 750 Zuschauer, das ist gut.
Das ist wirklich gut.
Das war Irelaflash hier, ne? Oh, nice.
Mit 7 mein ich.
Da je nach.
Wie viel Spielzeit hat er insgesamt? Spielzeit seit... Ach, seit 2021.
Ich habe nämlich nur gelesen 1300 Stunden, da dachte ich mir,
das ist aber nicht viel.
Aber seit 2021 ist das durchaus nicht wenig.
Wir haben verloren, actually, das Game.
Ich glaube, wir haben das Game verloren.
Nach der Schule habe ich mir gedacht, wie jeder andere Mensch,
okay, was mache ich jetzt? Eine Ausbildung oder Studium?
Weil ich möchte studieren, das macht man irgendwie so.
Und dann habe ich gedacht, was könnte da in die Richtung kommen?
Da habe ich einmal digitale Medien gehört.
Und dann habe ich das auch gemacht.
Aber während dem Studium habe ich sehr schnell gemerkt,
dass nach einem, zwei, vielleicht drei Semestern,
wenn ich das weitermache, weiß ich nicht wirklich, ob ich glücklich werde.
Und genau während dieser Zeit, also durch das Studium,
konnte ich bei der Uniliga teilnehmen.
Und da, im Gegensatz, war ich Feuer und Flamme.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, wow, jeden Tag bitte 10 Stunden, 12 Stunden,
ich möchte das durchgehend machen.
Nach so einem Game mache ich Chat auf und gucke mir so an,
was mein Chat dazu zu sagen hat.
Chat, was habt ihr zu dem Game zu sagen?
Kannst du mal ein paar Liegestütze machen für die Doku?
Vielleicht ist das ein guter Punkt, weil wir machen nämlich,
für jeden Tod machen wir normalerweise eine Liegestütze.
Das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee.
Da hat man einen Grund dafür, dass sich ein bisschen zu bewegen im Stream.
Ich fahre mit High IQ.
Nicht, dass ich jetzt damit anfangen würde oder so,
aber an sich ist das eine gute Idee.
Der Chat kann das leider nicht sehen, weil die Kamera zu weit oben ist,
aber für lohnt sich das.
Der Chat muss einfach glauben, dass er es macht.
Der ist aber aufgestorben.
Damit man hier nicht ganz verkümmert am PC.
Ich habe jetzt 1100 Zuschauer nach 3,5 Stunden, das ist sehr gut.
Jetzt sind es 1000, immer noch gut.
Und jetzt ab ins nächste Game.
Ich habe leider keins kaltgestellt, glaube ich.
Nein, kein Kalt, schade.
Aber halbwegs warm, also Zimmertemperatur geht das auch.
Das ist ein guter Hinweis, ich muss auch was trinken.
Dann geht es wieder ins Stream.
8 Stunden ohne etwas zu essen, halte ich nicht aus.
Das heißt, er trinkt Müllermilch, oder was?
Zum Mittagessen?
Gott sei Dank gar nichts, dank dem Partner.
Man kann sich schon eine Pause gönnen.
Was ist das denn?
Was ist das?
J-Food?
Für sich Mahlzeit?
Das ist bestimmt nicht gut bei Sodbrennen, oder?
Er hat keine Zeit zum Essen.
Fils Batman.
Der soll das machen wie Dance Gaming.
Dance Gaming hatte mal einen komischen...
Was war das?
Einen Sponsor, wo er in jedem Stream...
Er hat eine heiße Tasche gefuttert.
Hot Pocket.
Jeden Stream hat er eine heiße Tasche gefuttert.
Für meine Performance.
Aber sobald hier in dieser Kamera kein Mensch zu sehen ist,
denken sich einige Zuschauer, die wollen nicht mehr zugucken.
Ihr seid Gemeinschat.
Das Ding ist durch.
Das finde ich sehr schön.
Jetzt zeige ich mal.
2,6 Euro.
Da muss er wahrscheinlich noch Steuern drauf bezahlen.
Das ist schlecht. Mal gucken, was sie dazu sagen.
Wenn er da noch Steuern drauf bezahlen muss,
bleibt einem allzu viel übrig.
Normalerweise würde ich ausgehen,
dass es noch zu versteuern ist.
Aber vielleicht ist es auch das, was am Ende rauskommt.
Es variiert sich schon sehr.
Es kommt darauf an, wie der Stream läuft.
Man muss sagen, das klingt erst mal viel.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das ein guter Wert ist,
wenn man im Durchschnitt 1.000 Zuschauer hat.
Wahrscheinlich sind es im Durchschnitt gar nicht.
Ich denke, das ist ein ganz guter Wert.
Ich kann das jetzt Twitch schlecht einschätzen.
Meine Verdienste über Twitch halten sich durchaus in Grenzen.
Ich mache hier nichts.
Ich verdiene über Twitch, ich mache hier nichts zusätzliches.
Das Einzige, was ich habe, ist das Hetzner-Placement,
das mit integriert war.
Das waren Sellout-Geschichten.
Aber wenn man nur von Twitch ausgeht,
was verdiene ich denn bei Twitch?
500 Euro oder so.
Was auch richtig krass ist,
wenn ich mal eine Phase habe, dass ich viel und lange streame,
ist es halt einfach mal doppelt so viel.
Es ist wirklich krass,
wie sehr es auf die Sub-Zahlen und Zuschauer-Zahlen
Einfluss hat auf Twitch, ob du viel und lang streamst.
Bei mir ist es natürlich auf Twitch,
kann ich nicht so viel zu sagen.
Aber wo ich was zu sagen kann, ist,
wenn du viel und lang streamst,
ist es eine sehr beruhigende Sache.
Das ist nicht einfach von heute auf morgen weg.
Subscribereinnahmen sind höchstwahrscheinlich auch nicht
von heute auf morgen weg, aber das fluktuiert sehr stark.
Du hast dann beispielsweise im Dezember,
das sehe ich ja gerade auf YouTube,
was CPM angeht,
am Ende des Jahres geht es krass rauf
und dann geht es wieder in den Keller.
Das schwankt sehr.
Wenn du irgendwelche festen Sponsoring-Geschichten hast,
viele haben beispielsweise Elgato oder Monster Energy
oder keine Ahnung.
Bei mir war es jetzt auch ein bisschen hetzner.
Das ist eine sehr beruhigende Geschichte,
weil du weißt, was du rausbekommst.
Egal, ob das jetzt an Content gebunden ist
oder einfach nur an Einblendungen.
Du kannst dich einfach ein bisschen drauf verlassen.
Das finde ich ist eine sehr beruhigende Sache
und ich denke mal, das wird ihm auch so gehen.
Gucken wir mal weiter. Danke für den Sub.
Der Wolle hat subscribt und ein Abo geschenkt.
Doppelt Pock-Subscription hier.
Dann bist du jetzt dabei. Ich sehe es hier gar nicht.
Warum ist die Anzeige auf Twitch schon wieder so broken?
Was ist denn hier los? Vielleicht steht es hier.
Nö.
Normalerweise bin ich jetzt total blöd im Kopf.
Normalerweise steht da doch, wie lange er subscribt hat.
Ach nee, er hat gegiftet.
Ich habe es nicht. Guck mal.
Er ist Pro-Streamer, ich definitiv nicht.
Einfache Dinge, die ich nicht erkenne.
Aber noch mal ein bisschen zu dem Geld.
Irgendwelche Sponsoring-Sachen sind natürlich sehr beruhigend.
Aber trotzdem, er muss am Ende wahrscheinlich, keine Ahnung,
40% Steuern oder irgendwas drauf bezahlen.
Ich rate das jetzt einfach mal. Ich habe keine Ahnung.
40% Steuern oder so etwas drauf bezahlen.
Das heißt, da ist schon mal, oder sagen wir mal ein Drittel,
ein Drittel ist schon mal weg an Steuern.
Und dann muss er natürlich auch gucken, was ist.
Wenn er mal krank wird,
was ist, wenn er mal sich behandeln lassen muss irgendwie.
So Dinge.
Krankenversicherung, Altersvorsorge, alles mögliche Dinge.
Und da ist dann wirklich, also wenn man das macht,
der Kokona-Style ist ja Scheiß auf Krankenversicherung,
Scheiß auf Altersvorsorge.
Einfach jetzt direkt, gib ihm alles.
Aber wenn er das macht, dann bleibt von diesen 2600 Euro
deutlich, deutlich weniger übrig.
Als was man bei einem normalen Job monatlich bekommt.
Überwiesen bekommt wohlgemerkt, nachdem man Steuern bezahlt.
Und das ist natürlich ein Ding,
wo man sich dazu berufen fühlen muss irgendwie.
Für ihn ist das ja, sagen wir mal,
Einnahme, Arbeit und Spaß gleichzeitig.
Dann geht das, kann man das machen.
Und wenn man weiter wächst,
dann gibt es natürlich auch mehr.
Aber es muss ja immer wahrscheinlich klar sein,
dass man das auch nicht ewig machen kann.
Da muss man gucken, dass man seine Schäfchen ins Trockene kriegt.
Weil die Sache, was man da nachmacht, ist sowas,
was ich mir bei vielen Streamern kritisch vorstelle.
Vielleicht spricht da der Boomer aus mir, keine Ahnung.
Aber gerade Leute,
ich hab es halt bei manchen Overwatch-Pros verfolgt,
als mich das Game noch interessiert hat.
Die sind da mehr oder weniger 16, 17, 18 Meter reingerutscht.
Haben dann zwei Jahre OWL gespielt,
haben ein bisschen gestreamt.
Jetzt interessiert sich kein Mensch mehr dafür.
Ein paar haben die Transition zu
Variety-Streaming geschafft, ein paar nicht.
Was machen die jetzt?
Die sind nach der Schule Overwatch-Pro geworden und jetzt?
Die sind immer noch jung, die können immer noch alles machen.
Aber stelle ich mir teilweise doch ein bisschen schwierig vor.
Und wenn du das dann auch gemacht hast,
hat es wahrscheinlich auch keinen Bock mit, keine Ahnung,
30 irgendwie eine Ausbildung zu machen noch mal.
Oder vielleicht doch noch was zu studieren.
Da hält man sich wahrscheinlich auch die Lust in Grenzen.
Schwierig, keine Ahnung.
Also ich denke mal, dass er ganz gut davon leben kann,
aber sicherlich nicht im Geld schwimmt,
das mag bei Montana Black oder sonst wem der Fall sein,
aber nicht bei normalen Regionen.
Und am Ende, keine Ahnung,
da geht ein Drittel von weg.
Sagen wir mal, 2.000 Euro, 1.800 Euro oder so
nach den Steuern.
Dann noch ein bisschen Krankenversicherung,
vielleicht Altersvorsorge und sonstiges.
Wahrscheinlich hat er am Ende des Monats 1.500 Euro vielleicht,
was bei ihm wirklich ankommt.
Davon muss er natürlich das machen, was wir alle machen müssen.
Essen kaufen, Strom bezahlen,
Dinge tägliche, sonstige Ausgaben.
Also im Geld schwimmen tut man mit der Größe auf Twitch
eindeutig nicht.
Also es kommt darauf an, wie der Stream läuft.
Ob ich viele Zuschauer habe, wenig Zuschauer,
die donaten, also die Zuschauer auf Twitch haben ja die Möglichkeit,
mir einfach...
Er müsste einfach noch Leute NFTs scammen.
Geld zu schenken.
Moment, dass man von 800 Viewern leben kann, das liegt an genau einer Sache.
Das ist, wir klammern mal sponsoring Sachen aus,
da war das vielleicht früher auch schon möglich, das ist eindeutig,
wer weiß ist Chat...
Prime, richtig.
Hätte wahrscheinlich ein Viertel an Subs.
Rat ich jetzt.
Ich kann schlecht was dazu sagen, weil
es hat mich ja lange Zeit, ich habe lange Zeit gebraucht,
bis ich mal angefangen habe hier von YouTube
rüber auf Twitch und bis ich dann überhaupt mal Partner eingereicht.
Leute, ich habe hier irgendwie zweieinhalb Jahre gestreamt, ohne Partner einzureichen und sowas.
Bei mir gab es von Anfang an, fast von Anfang an Prime.
Also ich kann es jetzt nicht direkt vergleichen.
Aber
ich gehe davon aus, dass Prime Zahlen
bestimmt 50% der Subscriber ausmachen.
Bei mir noch mehr, das weiß ich.
Und
Prime hat, wie gesagt,
ich kann es ja auch nur vermuten, aber dafür
gesorgt, dass auch mittelgroße Streamer davon überleben können.
Ja, dabei habe ich
auch schon mal eineinhalb Jahre liegen lassen.
Einfach NFT Scams machen, easy.
Und dann gibt es die Sponsorings.
Da ist auch immer die Frage, welche Sponsoring kriegst du?
Kriegst du überhaupt ein Sponsoring oder musst du schauen, dass du nur mit den Twitch einnimmst?
Snaggy, Snaggs, danke für den Sub.
Ich merke, dass ich jetzt viel gespielt habe.
Zuschauer haben wir jetzt gerade 761.
Das ist quasi diese Tendenz, die ich am Anfang angesprochen habe.
Und dann bauen wir langsam ab. Das ist normal.
Das ist noch gut. Also ich sage mal so.
700 Zuschauer finde ich toll.
Leute, soll ich euch mal sagen, was ich toll finde?
Zuschauer, Zuschauer, Zuschauermenge.
Erstens finde ich jeden einzelnen toll, der regelmäßig einschaltet.
Kann man so pauschal jetzt erst mal sagen.
Ihr wisst, ich bin nicht mal in der großen Worte, was Rumschleim am Chat angeht.
Ich flame euch öfters mal ein bisschen an.
Aber das muss man echt sagen. Ich finde es wirklich toll,
dass ich so viele Leute hier auch erkenne und wiedererkenne.
Wenn ich den Chat durchgucke, die meisten habe ich schon hier gesehen.
Den Stripes habe ich schon gesehen, den Rosario habe ich schon gesehen.
Angel habe ich glaube ich hier auch schon öfters gesehen, Couch habe ich schon gesehen.
Den Namen kannte ich nicht, aber seine Emotes kenne ich.
Die verwendet er öfters.
Elevencore ist öfters am Start, Baumi ist am Start, Notizblock ist am Start.
Der Homer ist am Start, Captain Peng ist am Start.
Wirklich viele vom Namen her, das finde ich cool.
Kennst du mich auch?
Also wenn ich so direkt frage, sagt mir jetzt erst mal pauschal nichts.
Heals Batman. Aber jetzt, aber ab jetzt hoffentlich schon.
Aber was ich halt nice finde, ist Leute regelmäßig zu sehen.
Das finde ich wirklich cool.
Und was ich halt auch sehr, was ich wirklich unglaublich motivierend an Twitch finde,
im Vergleich zu YouTube.
Auf YouTube ist es auch so, du hast auch die üblichen Verdächtigen,
die Kommentare schreiben.
Du hast auch die üblichen Verdächtigen, aber was ich hier halt mega nice finde,
du machst den Stream an, du guckst mal kurz nicht auf den Chat
und auf einmal sind irgendwie 20 Leute da und denkst ja okay,
die 80% davon sind immer da.
Das ist wirklich, wirklich nice. Nee, aber jetzt mal zu dieser Zahl,
wo ich sag, wo ich immer zufrieden bin.
Anbetracht des Contents, was ich mache, das ist jetzt ja auch nicht,
ja ist so, das soll ich sagen,
das ist nicht das GTA Roleplay.
Könnte ich eh nicht machen.
Ich sag mal, wenn ich 200 Zuschauer habe,
bin ich zufrieden.
Find ich gut.
Felby, danke für den Sound, danke für die huge Subgifts.
Jetzt geht's ab. Also die meisten haben erstmal gedodged im Chat.
Habt ihr gut gemacht. Wer hat denn was gekriegt?
Condizio.
Ist bestimmt irgendwas Lateinisches oder so.
Artino, Lousy,
MikeGero und Patrick haben was gekriegt. Huge Subscriptions.
Ach ja.
Ja und ich fände es mal wieder geil,
wenn ich nicht so viel husten müsste.
Das ist zum Stream sicherlich auch nicht so toll,
wenn ich euch laufen ins Ohr huste.
Richtig, richtig huge Emotes.
Emotes ist eh ein gutes Thema.
Ich hab glaube ich noch 13 Emote Slots oder sowas frei.
Kennt ihr jemand, ohne Scheiß,
kennt ihr jemand, der jetzt nicht
ultra klein ist auf Twitch oder YouTube,
also jemand so in meiner Größe, der ähnlich faul ist wie ich,
was sowas angeht.
Ich tausche nie Weihnachts Emotes aus.
Ich beauftrage nie neue Emotes.
Ja der Solution ist auch ein fauler Sack, das stimmt.
Deswegen hab ich mich wahrscheinlich mit dem Frühjahr gut verstanden.
Faule Säcke verstehen sich untereinander.
Das stimmt.
Aber so schlimm wie bei mir ist doch wirklich selten, oder?
Schwarz gesehen, danke für den Sub.
C-Hop auch am Start.
Oder ist es eher C-E-Hub?
Keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht, aber das ist auch ein fauler Sack.
Das ist wie ich in der Richtung.
Gibt es auch mal welche in Auftrag?
Ich weiß, das ist eigentlich ganz einfach, aber ich kümmere mich um so Dinge nie.
Es ist teilweise eh, manchmal, manchmal,
ihr werdet es nicht glauben.
Aber es ist legit.
Das letzte Jahr Elgato-Sponsoring, was ich gemacht habe,
2000, fragt mich nicht, wann das war.
Ich sag jetzt einfach mal 2015, ist auch egal, wann das war.
Das letzte Jahr Elgato-Sponsoring,
das darfst du eigentlich gar keinem erzählen.
Die Leute denken, Max, du hast es nicht mehr alle.
Das letzte Jahr Elgato-Sponsoring, was ich gemacht habe, ist,
ich hab erst zwei Jahre später
gemerkt, dass ich denen noch keine Rechnung geschrieben habe.
Das musst du erst mal auf die Reihe kriegen.
Alter, das hat Corona hier angesagt.
Meine Güte.
Zwei Jahre später.
Nicht Stonks, nein, nicht Stonks.
Aber jetzt hab ich ja glücklicherweise einen Manager,
der sich ein bisschen um so was mitkümmert.
Weil ansonsten...
Oh man.
Pains Champ.
Ja, für dich, für die ist das gut, die muss nichts bezahlen.
Ja, Not Stonks gibt's.
Oh man.
Okay, wir gucken, als das Video war fertig.
Nein, keine Mario Kart Musik.
Erst mal das Video fertig gucken.
Ich hab jetzt ganz vergessen, was er gesagt hat.
Also ich sag immer so, alles über 700 Zuschauer finde ich toll.
Oh mein Gott.
Eine andere Sache, die ist auf Twitch
einfacher Wert zu schätzen.
Weil du direkt siehst, wie viele Leute sind aktiv,
wie viele Leute chatten, wie viele Leute gucken zu.
Du weißt quasi fast jegliche
Zuschauerzahlen irgendwie zu schätzen.
Wenn du frisch anfängst und eins, zwei Zuschauer hast,
findest du es mega geil.
Bist du dann irgendwann mal bei 15, findest du es mega geil.
Das ist auf YouTube dadurch, dass YouTube so extrem schwankt,
schwierig.
Also ich muss sagen, ich bin auf YouTube mit einem Video
fast nicht zufrieden, wenn es keinen grünen Pfeil hat.
Dabei haben die meisten Videos keinen grünen Pfeil, weil grüner Pfeil bedeutet
überdurchschnittlich und es kann ja nicht jedes Video überdurchschnittlich sein.
Aber YouTube schwankt das so krass.
Du hast teilweise Videos, die haben, keine Ahnung,
nach einer Woche 20.000.
Nach einer Woche 80.000.
Oder teilweise, wenn es ganz extrem ist, 100.000.
Das ist auf Twitch deutlich konstanter.
Wir haben gewonnen.
Wir haben gewonnen, finally.
Ich habe jetzt ziemlich genau 8 Stunden
und 6 Minuten gestreamt.
Nach 18 Jahren, glaube ich, das erste Mal angefangen zu investieren,
dann waren es 25 Euro im Monat.
Aber jeder, der sich damit auskennt, weiß, es ist wichtig,
überhaupt erstmal anzufangen.
Ja, teils, teils.
Das erste Video kam gut an, die nächste nicht.
Das erste IT-Jobs-Video kam sehr gut an, das nächste
mittelmäßig, das nächste wieder richtig gut.
Danach wieder mittelmäßig, dann wieder besser.
Wahrscheinlich liegt es auch an mir.
Ich müsste wahrscheinlich mit mehr Clickbait anfangen.
Mehr spektakuläre anfangen.
Ich müsste mir wahrscheinlich
so ein richtig krasses Ding raussuchen, das die ersten 2 Minuten zeigen.
Egal, wir schauen jetzt erstmal
endlich mal das Video fertig.
Also probiere ich so viel Geld, wie ich kann, zu sparen.
Ohne mich jetzt im Leben zu stark zu beschränken.
Ich überlege schon, muss ich da jetzt im Restaurant
für 80 Euro essen gehen oder kann ich mir auch einen Döner holen?
80 Euro ist ja schon krass.
Ich meine, 80 Euro Restaurant ist scheiße, ist teuer geworden, Leute.
Ich wollte letztens beim Pizza Hut bestellen, die wollten 22 Euro
für eine publische Pizza.
22 Euro Pizza Hut.
Für 22 Euro kann ich bei mir um die Ecke Schnitzelplatte futtern
für 2 Personen.
Wir werden jetzt zur Sache auch aufhören
zu streamen und wenn ihr jetzt richtig toll sein wollt,
dann seid ihr heute um 20 Uhr am Start.
Weil um 20 Uhr heute
spielen wir die europäische
Uniliga-Meisterschaft nicht,
sondern ein Turnier, das wir uns dafür qualifizieren.
Und ansonsten, falls ihr da keine Zeit habt, was anderes lasse ich nämlich nicht zählen,
sehen wir uns morgen, 7.45 Uhr.
Also, wir sind chat. Danke für unseren Support.
Und streamen aus.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er noch studiert.
Wahrscheinlich studiert er offiziell noch, weil er irgendwo eingeschrieben ist oder so.
Aber geht nirgends wobei hin.
Das ist das letzte. Also das ist meistens auch so das Minimum,
würde ich schätzen.
Ja gut, das liegt aber auch daran, das habe ich auch schon gemerkt,
das interpretiere ich jetzt mal wieder rein.
Aber Leute merken, wenn der Stream zu Ende geht,
also wenn ich sage, ah Leute, jetzt so langsam, aber sicher wird es mal Zeit,
ich muss essen, blablabla, so in der Richtung,
dann sehe ich immer instant, okay, 50 Leute dropen. Warum?
Ja gut, warum sollten die weiter zugucken, wenn die wissen,
ich mache eh in den nächsten fünf Minuten aus.
Also die Stream-Endezahlen kann man nie gucken.
Würde ich schätzen, so 450 vielleicht,
wirklich das Minimum.
Egal was ich mache, egal was ich streame, welche Spiele.
Das finde ich übrigens, wie ich gesagt habe, ich finde das mega nice.
Gerade auf Twitch, das ist unglaublich motivierend,
dass man immer die gleichen Leute am Start hat.
Man kennt die Leute einfach schon vom Namen her.
Mehr will ich euch gar nicht kennen. Vom Namen her reicht mich.
Ihr wisst, was soziale Sachen angeht, ist eh nicht meins.
Aber es ist jetzt zu viel, wenn wir Stimmung schieben.
Ich bin jetzt mit meiner Freundin ungefähr ziemlich genau ein Jahr zusammen.
Und ich habe ihr gesagt, ich möchte erst zusammenziehen,
wenn ich an dem Punkt bin, wo ich sagen kann, okay,
die fixen Kosten kann ich sicher jeden Monat alle decken.
Mittlerweile bin ich an dem Punkt, wo ich sagen kann,
ich muss mir nicht Gedanken darüber machen, dass ich das Geld zusammenkriege.
Schaust du in den Stream rein, normalerweise?
Ja, ab und zu mache ich das.
Das muss ich mir gerade nochmal anhören.
Ja gut, Stream. Ja gut.
Wie willst du es auch sonst aus? Ich spreche sehr absichtlich Stream aus.
Normalerweise?
Ja, ab und zu mache ich das.
Die kommt rein und denkt sich, what the fuck macht der da eigentlich?
Dann schreibe ich ihm mal kurz was rein.
Eigentlich antwortet er immer mit den Zuschauerzahlen.
Leider, muss ich sagen.
Wir arbeiten gerade daran, oder er arbeitet daran,
dass ihm schlechte Spiele und schlechte Zuschauerzahlen
nicht so beeinflussen sollen.
Das ist natürlich ein Ding, ja, das verstehe ich.
Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen, ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Das ist eines der Punkte, warum ich nie wirklich gesagt habe,
ich will den Kram mal hauptberuflich machen.
Twitch ähnlich, aber YouTube.
Das ist der Grund, weil mich fuckt das jetzt schon teilweise ab,
wenn gute Videos teilweise nicht geguckt werden
und es kommt nicht an und so was.
Wenn du dann noch weißt, oder umgedreht, was mich auch nervt,
wenn ich sehe, ich mache was zu einem Thema
und denke mir, Leute, das ist ein richtig gutes Video zu dem Thema
und ich sehe in einem anderen Video zu dem Thema,
was ich mega kacke finde, was dann aber 3-mal so viel aufruft,
regt mich das auf.
Das regt mich jetzt auf, obwohl da für mich jetzt nicht
die finanzielle Existenz dranhängt.
Ich sehe, wie das erst ist, wenn da wirklich
dein Leben von abhängend übertrieben gesagt,
von Zuschauerzahlen, Subscriberzahlen, Sponsorings, Donations.
Was meint ihr, wenn es wirklich quasi,
ich nenne es jetzt mal übertrieben, um es überleben geht,
dann ist ja kein Wunder.
Dann regst du dich nicht nur auf,
weil es irgendwie rein um deinen Content geht
oder man regt sich auch manchmal über sich selbst auf,
wenn ich mir gedacht habe, Max, Mann, bist du doof,
das Video ist eigentlich richtig gut gemacht,
aber du hast den Anfang so verschissen, kein Wunder,
dass das keiner guckt und so was.
Aber da geht es ja wirklich noch um mehr.
Und dann hast du nicht nur so dieses Mädge,
wo man sich drüber aufregt, sondern auch noch zusätzlich
nach dem Motto, fuck, was mache ich denn jetzt,
wenn das 5 Videos in Folge so ist, dann habe ich kein Geld?
Nein.
Jetzt gibt es das Halbfinale
von einem Turnier, was wir spielen,
im Uni-Liga-Kosmos, sag ich mal.
Was ich übrigens cool finde, dass er sagt, wir spielen.
Das mache ich auch gerne.
Was ich überhaupt nicht mag,
ist Leute, die Zuschauer mit du anreden.
So nach dem Motto, ich zeige dir heute
ein XY-Sensor für dein Smart Home, damit auch du weißt,
wie du dein Smart Home in Zukunft sicher gestaltest und so was.
Ich weiß nicht, ich komme auf wie du an Sprache
mit Zuschauern nicht klar.
Immer wenn wir was im Stream machen, ich sage immer wir.
Und wir heißt bei mir der Chat und ich.
Und das sage ich auf YouTube auch.
Und ich sage auf YouTube auch immer euch und so was.
Ich kann das mit du nicht ab.
Das kommt ja noch dazu.
Aber
ich bevorzuge auch eindeutig wir und euch
als du.
Ich glaube, die Leute auf YouTube
machen das, weil das persönlicher wirken soll.
Aber ich finde, das cringet irgendwie.
Das ist quasi der
Qualifier, dass wir
uniliga europaweit spielen können.
Ja.
Hey, eine Sache, die ich in LoL
kenne, ist dieses komische Monster,
was einem irgendeinen Buff gibt, wenn man es killt.
Ansonsten habe ich keine Ahnung von, aber das kenne ich.
Und ich weiß, dass der Mob nach irgendeinem Entwickler
benannt ist.
Der Mob ist nach irgendeinem,
das ist rückwärts der Entwicklernahme oder irgendwie
sowas. Das habe ich auch mal irgendwo gelesen.
Ansonsten LoL, kein Plan.
Ich habe 50 Sekunden 2.
Over and over and over and over and over.
Like a monkey with a miniature symbol.
The joy of.
Immer im OGA, ja gut, ja gut.
Ist aber wenig.
Also Amazon Reflings
wundert mich, dass das so wenig ist. Warum ist das?
Donations sind
outsides Prime Subs gibt. Ich habe ja auch mein Donationszeug
komplett entfernt. Aber Reflings ist ganz schön
wenig.
Also ich kann mich noch dran erinnern.
Ich hatte mal 2000, wo ich
noch richtig Amazon Reflings
promoted habe auf YouTube und wo dann auch die Leute
alle wissen wollten, wie ist das Mikrofon, welche Maus, wie nimmst du auf
und so. Da hatte ich mal an Weihnachten glaube ich über 2000 Euro.
Amazon.
Deswegen erscheint mir 28 Euro doch etwas.
Gut, die Reflingszahlen sind auch runtergegangen.
Die bezahlen auch nicht mehr so viel wie früher.
Also das war noch so die Hochzeit von Amazon.
Wie heißt der Kram nochmal?
Nicht AdSense.
Ich werde vergessen wie das Amazon Partner Programm heißt.
Ja das war so die Hochzeit.
Mittlerweile gibt es weniger für Reflings. Amazon ist da ein bisschen
gnauserisch geworden.
Aber das hätte ich gedacht, dass es mehr ist.
Chat sagt gerade, der eine Streamer,
wo ich täglich schaue, macht jeden Tag
120 zu jeden Monat, was? Jeden Tag mehr Donations.
Wo?
Dann hast du noch so Streamer wie MontanaBlack, wo 12-Jährige
erstmal in Taschengelder unten hängen.
Werde ich auch nicht verstehen.
Aber okay.
So, was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Also das die Leute da donaten, sollen sie machen.
Aber was ich nicht verstehe ist, warum man...
Warum muss man sein Taschengeld donaten?
Und du hast halt eben sau viele jüngere Zuschauer.
Ich weiß überhaupt...
Ich verstehe nicht, warum man da sein Geld für raushaut.
Aber es ist so.
Es ist so.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum man da sein Geld für raushaut.
Also für nichts. Es geht nicht mal, ob es jetzt
MontanaBlack ist oder sonst was. Ich würde mit 13 niemals
mein Geld spenden an einen Twitch-Streamer.
Schau, das Video ist doch fertig.
Ah nee.
Ich glaube, das ist durch.
Okay. Streamstuff.
Versicherung.
Siehst du, Leute, wir haben nicht schlecht
geschätzt mit den Steuern, oder?
Wir haben gesagt, er hat am Ende nach den Steuern
1800 Euro raus. Und was sind das?
1750 ungefähr.
Das ist nicht geschätzt, oder?
Sparen.
Jawoll.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Sowohl finanziell als auch emotional.
Der Wert für mich als Streamer ist unbezahlbar.
Wie alt er ist? 22, glaube ich.
Das war jetzt das Video. Ihr habt meinen Tag verfolgt.
Ich hoffe, es hat euch gefallen.
Dann wird es billiger, aber
es könnte auch relativ schnell viel teurer werden.
Hier kommt noch ein Video und hier kommt
auch ein Video. Und abonnieren und die Glocke nicht vergessen.
Bis dahin. Ciao, ciao.
Das war ein gutes Video.
So, was gucken wir uns dann
an? Was soll ich mir angucken? Die JavaScript-Report
wollte ByteStrikes sehen. Ja, die wollte ich mir eher angucken.
Shocking state of JavaScript
Code-Report. Na dann, auf geht's.
Der Typ macht übrigens
richtig... Ach, Moment, ist das der GitHub?
Ist das der GitHub-Code-Report?
Nee, oder? Was?
Wo hat er die Zahlen her?
Ach nee, hier. Das ist was anderes.
Meinung zu
htmx. Okay, ich sehe, ich bin outdated.
Was ist htmx?
High-Power-Tools-for-html.
Aber ich kenne ihn nicht.
So, schauen wir uns mal an.
Die Videos sind oberflächig. Na ja, gut, es sind 3-Minuten-Videos.
Was soll er denn machen?
Shocking. Das erinnert mich
an die Ami-News.
YouTube war mal der Meinung, es muss mir eine ganze Weile
Fox News empfehlen. Fox News ist ja eh
der Meister, was das angeht, an Übertreibungen.
Und es ist wirklich alles
Shocking bei denen. Egal was ist,
Shocking, Shocking Revealed, irgendwie alles, alles
Shocking. Breaking Shocking.
Da gibt es nichts Normales.
Das ist wohl wahr.
Angular.
Na super, super.
Ember, Ember ist ganz weit unten.
Leute, ich hab mal was mit Ember gemacht vor,
als es neu war.
Irgendwie 2010 oder so. Und ich muss sagen, ich hab Ember nie verstanden
bis heute. Leute, mein Headset spackt mega rum.
Wartet mal kurz.
So, ich hab
Ember nie kapiert.
Bis zum Schluss nicht. Das war zu low IQ, bin ich dafür.
Und seit ich dann mal irgendwann gesagt hab, Scheiß drauf
und hab mich mit ein bisschen anderen Frontend Frameworks beschäftigt,
so richtig warm bin ich eigentlich noch mit Vue.js geworden, ist das viel besser.
Aber guckt mal hier. Angular ist unten
wahrscheinlich zurecht.
Wieso braucht man
eigentlich ein Framework? Ja gut, wenn du alles in Vanilla
JavaScript machen willst, viel Spaß, kannst du ja machen.
Aber es nimmt dir halt einiges an Arbeit ab. Gerade irgendwelche
Data-Binding-Geschichten und vor allem gerade was halt bei Vue
richtig gut ist, dass es für so ziemlich alles irgendwelche
fertigen Bindings gibt oder fertigen Libraries gibt.
Und ich könnte mir nicht vorstellen, beispielsweise
das Preis-Champ UI mit Vanilla
JavaScript zu machen und sowas. Können wir uns jetzt nicht angucken?
Ich hab es abgeschaltet, aber ja.
NPM, ja gut, NPM ist halt
ein schwarzes Loch. So, also Angular ist unten,
da kommt Stimulus, Preact, Lit,
Lit, das sagt mir irgendwas. Hab ich schon mal gehört.
Alpine, Vue.js, Vue.js ist runter.
Ah, interessant. Wisst ihr warum Vue.js
runter ist? Ich bin mir relativ sicher,
dass Vue.js runter ist. Vue.js ist runter, weil viele
Leute den Umstieg von der Options-API
auf die jetzt, sagen wir mal,
favorisierte, kann man nicht sagen,
auf diese neue Composition-Geschichte nicht so feiern.
Dabei kannst du Options
immer noch verwenden in Vue 3. Das ist das erste.
Und das zweite ist, und ich glaube, das spielt noch fast größere
Rolle, das Vue, das Ökosystem von Vue
ist unglaublich träge. Ich meine,
Vue 3 kam wann raus?
2020 oder so? Das ist ja schon irgendwie
1-2 Jahre quasi jetzt offiziell released. Und
bei, sag mal, UI-Frameworks wie
Vue.tify oder sowas haben bis heute
keine stable Vue 3
Version rausgebracht. Natürlich
sinkt da die Zufriedenheit für, weil aktuell
weißt du ja gar nicht, was du wirklich, was du nehmen sollst, gescheit.
Aber das Welt geht hoch, siehst du, Leute, wir haben das
Richtige gelernt. Wir gucken jetzt aber erstmal weiter.
Okay, okay.
Eins muss man ja überlassen, Angular
kann er wirklich nicht ab.
JavaScript-Developers jede Woche,
jedes Wochenende was Neues lernen wollen. Ehrlich gesagt,
doch glaube ich schon,
anders kann ich mir nämlich nicht erklären, dass nach wie vor
jede Woche irgendwelche neuen JavaScript-Repos trenden auf GitHub.
Aber eins muss man sagen, die 3
großen Frameworks, die sind jetzt die letzten
4-5 Jahre relativ stabil.
Also es ist React, Vue, Angular.
Und das seit den letzten 3, 4, 5 Jahren.
Also da in der Richtung tut sich nicht so viel.
Jetzt in den letzten Jahren ist noch Svelte dabei gekommen,
was ich eigentlich von der Idee her, mit diesem
wir übersetzen alles zu Vanilla JavaScript,
unter der Haube ist es alles Vanilla JavaScript, ja.
Aber den Ansatz, dass es quasi ein Framework
Schräg-Schräg-Compiler ist, finde ich, ist eigentlich der beste Ansatz.
Leider ist Svelte 3 Jahre zu spät gewesen.
Ansonsten wäre das
wahrscheinlich mit weit vorne, ja.
Wir gucken jetzt erstmal weiter.
Die Videos gucke ich mir auch ab und zu an von ihm.
Er lässt ja eigentlich nichts aus, um Angular zu flamen.
Das ist eigentlich schon die Fault bei ihm.
Kennt das noch jemand?
Also ich kann mich noch dunkel dran erinnern. Kennt noch jemand Gulp?
Das war irgendwie so ein
Bild-Job-Runner-Tool. Totaler Crap.
Crunt gab es auch noch. Crunt und sowas.
Und was gab es denn sonst noch?
Kennt noch jemand Bauer?
Oder Bauer oder sowas?
Das mit diesem Vogel als Logo.
Das war quasi NPM, bevor NPM da war.
Also das JavaScript-Ökosystem,
wenn man da Schritt halten will,
ist echt Paynes-Champ.
Ganz ehrlich, die letzten 5 Jahre
waren bestimmt 300
Libraries und 300 Tools voll angesackt
und jetzt sind wieder komplett in der Versenkung verschwunden.
Nein, nicht Ionic. Ionic ist immer noch gut dabei.
Ja, Veed ist echt nice.
Da hier! Hier!
Sag ich doch! Bauer? Das ist Bauer?
Und das Crunt-Ionic ist grausam.
Was ist denn das da oben?
Was ist denn das? Das Webpack?
Webpack? Okay.
Ja, Webpack ist auch so ein absoluter
pain in the ass.
Ja, das liegt daran an dem, was ich vermutet habe.
Ich denke, es liegt daran,
was ich eben vermutet habe.
Scheuer der Satz, aber ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Ja, genau, das ist das Ding.
Ja, das macht das Ökosystem komplexer
und dass die ganzen großen Libraries jetzt irgendwie 2 Jahre nach Release
oftmals, wie gesagt, ich guck mir da in No-Mutify an,
das nicht gepackt haben, eine neue Version rauszubringen.
Weißt du, wisst ihr, was ich bei dem Namen immer frage?
Das ist ja wahrscheinlich nicht sein richtiger Name.
Das ist so ein Fehler.
Ach, ja.
Das ist ein Fehler.
Aber es ist ein Fehler.
Das ist so ein Fehler.
Das ist ja wahrscheinlich nicht sein richtiger Name, oder?
Ich denke mal, das ist so diese Geschichte mit China-Name zu englischem Name.
Hat er sich absichtlich Evan Yu genannt, weil sich das ähnlich anhört wie Straße, oder
ist das Absicht?
Das ist keine Absicht.
Ich meine, er ist ja wahrscheinlich nicht mit dem Namen geboren.
Oder Evan Yu, irgendwie sowas, weil das sieht man ja öfters mal, wenn Leute aus China
sich englische Namen geben, da kommt dann teilweise schon ein bisschen abgedrehtes Zeug
raus.
Sein echter Name ist, okay, es hat tatsächlich was mit dem echten Namen zu tun.
Das Yu ist echt, okay.
Aber Webpack ist auch wirklich eklig.
War das nicht, war Gatsby nicht irgend so ein Static Site Ding, Static Site Generator
oder sowas?
Kann mir das ganze JavaScript Zeug nicht komplett merken.
Meistens bleibt der Nachname und nur da vorne mit Englisch.
Ach Quatsch, das ist ja, das war ja im Prinzip jedem klar, der sich ein bisschen damit beschäftigt
hat.
Das ist immer so.
Die Leute haben irgendwas Neues und sagen, jawoll, das ist das neue große Teil, was
jeder verwenden muss.
Aber ich meine, jedem sollte klar gewesen sein, von Anfang an, dass GraphQL nicht komplett
rest replaced.
Das sind alles seine Stärken und Schwächen, gerade wenn du komplexere Queries machen willst
mit Suche und Sortieren und vielleicht auch noch irgendwelchem Wildcard Matching oder
was auch immer.
Oder wenn du einen großen Datensatz hast, dass du einen Teil davon abfragen willst.
Es hat seinen Sinn, GraphQL zu verwenden.
Aber für so Sachen mit, User hat Knopf gedrückt, ist ein GetRequest, wenn man nicht eh in den
Websocket offen hat, einfach sinnvoller als ein GraphQL Endpoint.
Oh, warum ist SvelteKit so weit oben?
Also ich hatte jetzt ein paar Sachen, die haben mich an SvelteKit genervt, z.B. mag
ich den Router nicht.
Oder vielleicht habe ich es einfach nicht genau durchgestiegen.
Den Router, ja sorry, den Router war ich nicht.
Schreibt man Static Shit nicht immer in PlaneHTML?
Ne, ne, was damit gemeint ist, ist folgendes.
Mit Statisch ist nicht PlaneHTML gemeint.
Mit Static ist gemeint, dass du eine Web-Anwendung hast, wo durchaus JavaScript und sowas drin
sein kann, aber was du quasi self-contained baust, dass du kein Node.js-Backend mehr machen
brauchst, der irgendwelche Logik ausführt oder sowas, dass du quasi ein self-contained
HTML-Bundle rauskriegst mit JavaScript, mit CSS, mit HTML und allem drinnen und du kannst
die Seiten dann durchklicken, ohne dass du ein Backend brauchst, was JavaScript sonst
wie Logik ausführt.
Du brauchst einen Web-Server, du schiebst einen Bundle hin und die Seite funktioniert.
Ja, z.B. du hast einen Shop, du kannst den Shop natürlich machen mit Logik im Backend,
keine Ahnung, du machst einen Get-Request mit einer Item-ID, dann antwortest du mit
einem JSON-Objekt und dann rendert das dann die Produktseite da raus und sowas oder du
machst das mit einem Static Site Generator, der generiert dir dann halt 5000 Geschichten
und du packst auf einen Web-Server drauf und du kannst die Seite browseen ohne Backend,
was natürlich bei einem Shop ein bisschen schwierig ist, weil spätestens die Bestellung
und sowas, da brauchst du dann irgendeine Logik.
Warum du kannst Knopfdrücken oder auch ein Get-Request machen, warum nicht, das muss
kein Put und Update sein, ein Get-Request geht doch auch, also die Frage, was du noch
alles mit übertragen willst.
Chat sagt, wir programmieren jetzt im Unternehmen
eine Anwendung mit Plug-In-Framework, wo auch das Frontend erweitert werden kann, das ist
sehr ungeeignet für eine Single-Page-Application.
Warum?
Weil du kannst irgendwelche View-Komponenten nachladen oder so und die, also ganz ehrlich,
Plug-In-fähiges Frontend habe ich mir noch nie Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Noch nie, also das Problem habe ich noch nicht.
Single-Page ist einfach Spurz, das kann man nicht sagen, also du kannst weder sagen, server-side-generated
ist das beste, noch kannst du sagen, Single-Page ist das beste.
Das sieht man allein schon daran, dass es aktuell den Trend gibt, beides besser miteinander
zu verheiraten.
Ich meine, Single-Page-Application ist für Suchmaschinen scheiße, da sind wir uns einig,
weil diese Suchmaschinen nichts durchsuchen können.
Deswegen ist jetzt der aktuelle Trend ja, dass du server-side-generated-Content hast,
den hydratest und zum Client drüber schickst, also dass du die Pre-Renderst, dass du die
Seite Pre-Renderst, den JavaScript-State hydratest, das nennt sich so, das habe ich mir nicht
ausgedacht, und es dann als Klein-Side-Anwendung im Browser weiterläuft, was dazu führt,
dass du die Seiten mit der Suchmaschine gut indizieren kannst, dass das erste Laden der
Seite schneller geht und dass du weiter die Vorteile von der Klein-Side-Anwendung hast.
Das ist ja so der aktuelle Trend in dieser Richtung, gibt's egal, für Vue gibt's das,
für React gibt's das, für Svelte gibt's das auch, diese Kombination aus Single-Page-Applications
und Server-Side-Rendering.
Also, ich weiß gar nicht, wie das Pre-Rendern ist, guck mal, wie lange ich bei einem 3-Minuten-Video
brauche, schon heftig wieder, Moment, was, was, was, was, hab ich mich aufgepasst, Rust-Based
Alternative zu Electron, ist mal eine dumme Frage, ist nicht das, was viel RAM braucht
bei Electron, die Browser-Instance, weniger das Node.js, also ist jetzt ein Browser,
der JavaScript in Rust macht, wirklich so viel weniger RAM als Electron, ja, echt, warum?
RAM ist egal, weil, ansonsten seh ich da jetzt nicht den großen Vorteil davon, hm, muss,
muss ich mir mal angucken, Build, was, Build, Smaller, Faster, More Secure, Desktop-Applications,
Webfrontend, alles klar, oh, es läuft, es läuft nicht, es läuft nicht auf iOS und Android,
das find ich schon mal, find ich schon mal gut, nee, find ich eigentlich nicht gut, aber
wenigstens mal was, was auf Desktop Wert liegt, aha, ok, ok, Installer-Size-Linux, warum ist
Hauri so klein, da muss ein Browser dabei sein, und auch wenn mein Installer ist komprimiert,
aber, ach, ich weiß es wieder, Moment, war Hauri nicht das, was die Browser verwenden,
die vorinstalliert sind auf dem System, also die verwenden Webview auf Windows, die verwenden
Safari auf Mac und Firefox unter Linux, ach, die Geschichte ist das, ja, das hab ich schon
mal gesehen, da hab ich schon mal was drüber gesehen, ja, ja, aber jetzt erinnere ich mich
wieder, ja gut, das ist aber unter Linux da wahrscheinlich schwierig, wenn da, da kann
ja alles mögliche vorinstalliert sein, Memory Consumption, ok, das hätte ich echt nicht
gedacht, dass es so ein Unterschied ist, Backend Binding Underline Engine, ok, die machen JavaScript,
die machen tatsächlich JavaScript in Rust, da hätte ich mal eine Zweifel, ob JavaScript
in Rust schneller ist als V8, V8 dürfte so ziemlich die optimierteste JavaScript Engine
sein, die man findet, Multithreaded, ja, Spiker, vielleicht mal was, was man sich angucken
sollte, ich schreib mir das mal kurz auf die Streamideenliste, jetzt ist Hauri, vielleicht
mal was, was man sich angucken könnte, nicht schlecht, was mit meinem Bildschirm los ist,
ja, das können wir uns tatsächlich mal angucken, irgendwann demnächst, achso, der Desktop,
du meinst nicht mein Bildschirm, du meinst mein Desktop, ja, das muss so sein, das muss
so sein, ist Polybar gut, hab ich noch nie ausprobiert, warum sollte man seinen Desktop
Platz nicht nutzen, ja, das stimmt, ich muss sagen, im Vergleich zu früher ist JavaScript
heute durchaus angenehm zu verwenden, dass sie Async Await geklaut haben von C Sharp
war eines der besten Ideen schlechthin, wahrscheinlich war da Microsoft mit TypeScript nicht ganz
unschuldig dran, es war eines der besten Sachen, die sie mit JavaScript machen konnten, weil
ich mein, ihr erinnert euch wahrscheinlich noch an Zeiten, Moment, Moment, es gab noch
nicht mal Lambda Functions, erinnert ihr euch noch, erinnert sich noch jemand, natürlich,
ich dachte es in der Zeit, wo es noch keine Lambda Ausdrücke gegeben hat, das war wirklich
eklig, heute mit Async Await und modernen JavaScript Sachen ist es erträglich und das
ist eine Sache, JavaScript zeigt, dass modern machen nicht gleich, wie soll ich sagen, nicht
gleich unnötig komplex und inkonsistent machen bedeutet, ich mein, JavaScript war schon immer
inkonsistent, gibt ja sehr viele Meme-Bildchen mit True, Gleich, Gleich, True ist False und
solche Geschichten in JavaScript, aber wenn man mal den Weg vergleicht, vergleicht mal
den Weg von JavaScript die letzten Jahre über, nennen wir die letzten 10 Jahre JavaScript
mit den letzten, oder nennen wir die letzten 15 Jahre JavaScript mit den letzten 15 Jahren
C++, was sieht man daran? JavaScript hat sich in eine programmiererfreundliche Richtung
entwickelt, C++ hat sich einfach von einer undefinierten Massekacke in eine größere
undefinierte Massekacke entwickelt und also man sieht schon mit ein bisschen Hirn und
sinnvollem Featurepicken von anderen Sachen kann man was gutes basteln, was bei C++ ja
bis heute nicht funktioniert hat und bei C++ kommen noch dazu, dass die, obwohl sie zig
Standards und neues Geschiss gemacht haben, die Compiler den Kram so lahm implementieren,
dass die zwei Standards vorne dran sind, gibt es einen Compiler, der Module, der C++ Module
schon komplett unterstützt? Ja, bei C Sharp wird es, da muss ich sagen, bei C Sharp wird
es besser und schlimmer gleichermaßen, ich finde ihr Pattern Matching ist cool, aber
total over the top an vielen Stellen und auch nicht gerade verständlich in C Sharp, dafür
machen sie weiterhin coole neue Sachen, die ich auch für sehr sinnvoll halte. Objektorientierung
ist einfach Quatsch, das kann man, es ist einfach Quatsch zu sagen, dass irgendwas pauschal
einfach Quatsch ist. Objektorientierung funktioniert in den meisten Sachen ganz gut, man muss es
nicht übertreiben und man braucht keinen Manager Service Factory Singleton Factory Manager
Pattern oder was auch immer, also man muss es nicht komplett übertreiben, so wie das
Java Entwickler teilweise gerne machen, aber leichtes objektorientierte Ansatz und an
den Stellen, wo man in C Sharp ja mittlerweile auch viele funktionale Ansätze drin hat,
das zu benutzen, ist, finde ich, die beste Kombination. Ich finde, zu sagen, das eine
ist Quatsch und das andere ist Quatsch, ist Quatsch. Das beste ist, so wenig wie möglich
dafür zu verwenden, um das Problem, was man hat, so aussahrekräftig und elegant wie möglich
umzusetzen. Also man muss nicht, das ist, nehmen wir mal C++, wenn du einfach eine Schleife
machen kannst, musst du kein Template dafür basteln. Oder in C Sharp, du musst nicht
zwangsläufig irgendwelche Pattern Matching Geschichten verwenden, dreifach nestet, wenn
es zwei Ifs tun. Aber an den Stellen, wo man es braucht, ist gut, dass die Sprachen das
haben. Ja und sogar in C++ ist es gut, dass sie Templates haben. So sehr ich C++ Scheiße
finde, sind Templates noch eines der Sachen in C++, wo ich sagen muss, das gibt der ganzen
Sache noch irgendwie eine gewisse Existenzberechtigung.
Es gibt in C Sharp Leute, die übertreiben, das finde ich maßlos. Ich habe beispielsweise
mal einen Konferenztalk gesehen von einem, der hat allen Ernstes gesagt, das hier ist
schlecht, das ist nicht gut strukturiert und das sollte man nicht verwenden. Und dann hat
er ernsthaft ein Interface gemacht und dann habe ich mir gedacht, okay Leute, es ist vorbei.
Jetzt ist, jetzt übertreibt es aber mal. Also ich meine, Abhängigkeit auf das Standard
Library Date Time, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt kriegt man, also ich weiß gar nicht, was ich dachte,
irgendwann ist ja auch mal gut. Das hat eh jeder. Warum sollte ich das Standard Date
Time bitte schön über ein Interface ansprechen, dass ich Standard, mal davon abgesehen, dass
das Standard Date Time so seine Probleme hat, ja. Aber man kann es echt, echt übertreiben.
Was habe ich übersehen? F Sharp, nein, mit F Sharp habe ich noch wenig gemacht. So gut
wie gar nichts. Das einzige, was ich mit F Sharp gemacht habe, ist, ich habe mal, weil
es damals im Visual Studio Projekt Assistent drin war, mal ein F Sharp Projekt erstellt
und ausgeführt, habe ich hier wieder was mitgemacht. Ja, das stimmt schon. Und die
gleichen Leute, die ein I-Date-Time-Interface machen, das sind die, die dann über NPM is
odd und is even installieren. Ja, Wahnsinn.
Ja, richtig, richtig nice, Leute. Ich weiß nicht, ob, ob, keine Ahnung, ich blicke
bei den Namen nicht durch. Eines der besten Sachen, die JavaScript eingeführt hat in
letzter Zeit, ist das da. Richtig, richtig, richtig. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob sie
das von C Sharp geklaut haben, weil ich glaube, C Sharp hat es selbst wiederum geklaut. Aber
das ist eine unglaubliche Hilfe. Was das macht, ist, das checkt hier, ob das hier null ist
oder undefined oder null oder null oder, oder, oder was auch immer. Null in JavaScript, was
auch immer. Null in JavaScript ist ja, JavaScript null halt. Und das guckt, ob das hier null
ist. Und nur wenn das nicht null ist, ruft es dann die Funktion oder die Methode keqw
auf diesem null hier auf. Das ist äußerst praktisch, weil ansonsten hättest du vorher
machen müssen. Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie ich das überhaupt richtig mache in JavaScript.
In JavaScript hättest du vorher sonst was machen müssen. If null gleich, gleich, gleich
null, wie auch immer man das korrekt in JavaScript macht, das spart sehr viel, weil, weil es
könnte ja auch sowas hier sein. Und so hast du einfach gechained die Sachen aneinander
und ansonsten müsstest du hierfür nochmal einen if machen. Ach stimmt, ist not, stimmt,
stimmt, not null, würde wahrscheinlich auch funktionieren. Aber ich glaube, man versteht
was, was gemeint. Also das ist wirklich ein super, super nice Feature. Und was der Unterschied
ist zwischen Fragezeichen, Fragezeichen und oder, oder, habe ich auch noch nicht genau
gecheckt. Das ist optional chaining, was ich euch gerade gezeigt habe. Sieht aber kacke
aus. Ganz ehrlich, ganz ehrlich, ich finde, es sieht besser aus wie fünf nested ifs.
Und das ist das, und das ist das, wo sich JavaScript, dieses JavaScript Gremium, Gremium
und Standard macht Leute unterscheiden zum C++ Gremium. JavaScript Leute führen so Sachen
ein, weil sie sagen, ok, Programmierer sind damit unzufrieden, unsere Date-Time-ARP sagt,
wir machen mal eine neue Date-Time-ARP, die besser ist. Und was machen die Leute in C++?
Die haben auch vor nicht allzu langer Zeit eine neue Date-Time-ARP eingeführt, schon
ein paar Jahrchen her, die absolut eine komplette Zumutung ist zu benutzen. Man könnte es auch
einfach machen, ja. So, next. Video, achso, war Video überhaupt
nicht. So, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid. Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid, dass JavaScript immer
noch merkwürdig ist, aber sich Dinge geändert haben.
Alles klar, das mussten wir jetzt wissen. So, was haben wir dann als nächstes? Battlefield
Friends könnten wir gucken. Was ein Lehrer verdient, könnten wir gucken. Twitch verdient.
Playstation 3 Emulation auf dem PC. Ach ne, wir gucken uns den Typ an. Das wurde mir
vorhin vorgeschlagen. Home Lab in my Garage. Und ich weiß bis heute nicht, ob es Garage
oder Garage ist. Aber ich glaube, da sind sich Kokona und, ja, haben wir eigentlich
einen Ausdruck für Engländer? Ich mein, wir haben Bayern-Emoals, wir haben
Bayern-Emoals, wir haben Ami-Emoals, wir haben russische Emoals, wir haben aber kein UK-Emoal,
wir haben kein China, wir haben immer noch kein China-Chinesen-Emoal. Also ich verwende
meistens das hier stellvertretend auch für die Chinesen.
Was ist deine Meinung zu Anyrun? Zu was?
Was ist Anyrun? Ja, ich hatte letztens eine Mode gezeigt, das geht aber nicht. Das, was
der Chainlord gebaut hat, das China-Emoal, das würde aber noch nicht mal durch die Twitch-Kontrolle
durchgehen. Speedrun Any%? Ich hab keine Ahnung. Oder ist das irgendein Chebat? Wenn
man das ausspricht, sagt man eigentlich was ganz anderes.
WTF, was soll das? Wieso, was soll denn was? Kann ich das anklicken, dass irgendwas passiert?
Ok, was soll was, BiteStrikes? Zeig her. Wo ist das Problem? Was ist das Problem? Hä?
Was ist an den Streams jetzt das Problem? Ah, Celebrating Black Brilliance. Warum nicht?
Sonst Celebrate? Kann jeder Celebrateen, was er will. Wir sollten mal Celebrateen, dass
ich bald ordentlich was zu Mittag essen gehe. Obwohl es jetzt 11 Uhr ist. Hippo Fett Celebrateen
sollten wir. Overengineering Homelab? Das da? Moment, Moment. Das Video klingt nach
einem Video, das ich gucken will. Nee, finde ich nicht. So, jetzt gucken wir erst mal an,
was der Typ in seinem Homelab stehen hat. BiteStrikes auf die Diskussion hab ich keinen
Bock. Das hab ich aufgegeben, da in irgendeiner Art und Weise drüber zu diskutieren. Egal
was du machst, du piss immer Leute an. Es gibt auch genug Dinge, die ich nicht nachvollziehen
kann, aber manche Sachen muss man halt einfach so hinnehmen. Es gibt viele Sachen, die ich
nicht verstehe. Vor allem sind das immer Diskussionen, die übelst hitzig geführt
sind, anstatt mit ein bisschen Verstand. Egal. So, schauen wir mal, was hat der Typ in seiner
Garage stehen. Ich hoffe, dass das ein gescheites Audio hat, das Video. Weil gerade so Videos
von kleinen Channels, die haben oftmals ziemlich mieses Audio, ist mir schon öfters mal aufgefallen.
Wenigstens mal einer, der einen Rack hat, was nicht dieses komische StarTech-Rack ist,
was die ganzen Leute da bei den Amis immer haben. Die Amis haben alle das gleiche Rack.
Ja, auf, komm mal zum Punkt, Kollege. Also, für jedes M, was der sagt, wenn wir dafür
irgendwie ein Sub kriegen, dann wäre ich bald Millionär. Ich darf nichts sagen. Meine englische
Aussprache ist kacke und ein UK-Native-Speaker macht das sicherlich besser als ich. Ich finde
aber teilweise den UK-Dialekt so geil. Okay, weiter im Text. Weiter, weiter. Passiert hier,
passiert hier noch irgendwas. Oh, dann schwatzt er auch noch. Alles, was ich nicht abkann.
Okay, das gucken wir nicht. Alter, komm mal zum Punkt, Mann. Okay, er hat einen Storage-Server
am Start, nice. Aber RGB, wichtig, wichtig, wichtig. Oder hat er noch irgend so ein Ollis
Synology, NAS oder QNAP, ich erkenne es nicht. Okay, unsinnig. Das hätten wir uns auch sparen
können. Okay, schauen wir mal, was haben wir denn sonst noch bei YouTube, was wird einem
sonst noch so empfohlen? Nix. Guck mal, YouTube ist der Meinung, wir sollen unbedingt dieses
Video gucken. Okay, das geht noch eine Minute, zeig her. Coggers. Nice. Äh. Aha. Okay,
cool. Ich meine, cool, aber. Und jetzt? Genau, cool, I guess. Fällt mir auch nicht mehr dazu
ein. Nice, nice gemacht, ja. Coole Konstruktion, aber. Next. Oh. Jetzt flutscht's. Oh, oh,
oh. Jetzt flutscht's. Aha, gut, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid. Falls wir sowas mal in Lego bauen
wollen, wissen wir, wo wir nachgucken müssen. Ähm, was gucken? Komm, wir gucken, wir gucken,
wir gucken die neueste und wahrscheinlich einzigste Battlefield 2042 Battlefield Friends
Folge. Vielleicht kennt das ja noch der eine oder andere aus Battlefield 3 und 4 Zeiten.
Also damals, muss ich sagen, ich hab wie jede Battlefield Friends Folge geguckt und ich
muss sagen, die Folgen mit dem mit dem Colonel 100 sind bis heute immer noch die Highlights
für mich. Der Colonel 100, der auch den Heli gemessert hat. Worst Launch Ever, ja gut,
da können sie sich ein bisschen dran auslassen. Ich muss nur kurz gucken, ob die Launch-Loungestelle
gestimmt. PP-21, was sonst?
Was ist das? Das ist die PP-29? Ja, gib mir das. Was machst du? Ich mache es. Warte,
das ist der beste Typ. Leider ja. Oh, ich habe so viele Noten für dich. Ich bin sicher,
dass du es machst. Ja, nimm die Noten. Okay, Registrierung. Wahnsinn, schützt ein Typ,
nicht mal, nicht mal registrieren. Dann gehen wir gleich durch. Wir arbeiten daran. Ich habe
geschlafen in der Office für die letzte Woche, um das zu machen. Okay, ich war auch getötet
durch einen unbekannten Gegner. Ja, das geht auch. Gegner, all of a sudden. Das ist immer
noch ein Back. Ich kann meine Frau nicht mehr sehen, denn sie hat mich verlassen. Also,
glaubst du, du kannst es beenden? Ich weiß es nicht. Ich meine, sie wird nicht meine
Anrufe beantworten, aber das bedeutet... Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
wir reden nicht von deiner Verwaltung, wir reden von dem Spiel. Wie, das ist Schiel
jetzt, das ist verrückt. Er ist praktisch unbekannte. Oh nein, Scheiße, wie kaputt ist es?
So spät war der Recoil jetzt auch nicht. Lass mich raten, es funktioniert nicht. Ich
Ich wette jetzt das funktioniert nicht, weil sein Fuß gleich zeigt er den Fuß, der in der Fuß von ihm steckt in diesem Kasten dahinter oder sowas und deswegen kann er nicht rev... kann er nicht rev... ich kann nicht mehr reden. Revive.
Ah ne, ich dachte die zeigen den Fuß, der in der Wand steckt oder sowas.
Oh nein, der Noob. Der Noob sieht anders aus als früher.
Farbt der Waffen frei oder?
Das ist Spotlobby. Spotlobby.
Das trifft eigentlich ganz kurz.
Das war klar, das war klar.
Das haben die bis heute nicht gefixt, muss man sich mal vorstellen. Kein Witz, die haben das nie gefixt. Für alle die nicht dabei waren, die haben einen Patch veröffentlicht für Battlefield 2042, da konntest du deine Maus nicht mehr bewegen.
In einem Ego-Shooter am PC, du konntest deine Maus nicht mehr benutzen.
Wobei doch, ich glaube du konntest auch nach oben, nach unten, aber du konntest nicht mehr nach links und rechts gucken. Und die haben das nie, und das ist jetzt kein Witz, die haben es nie gepatcht, nie. Die haben darauf vertraut, dass die Leute ins Forum gucken, ihren Settings Ordner löschen und das Game wieder von vorne anlegen lassen.
Aber Maus bewegen ist eindeutig Legacy-Feature. Wer möchte auch seine Maus in einem Game bewegen können?
Oh Mann. Also das ist wirklich ein kompletter Reihenfall, das Game, und mehr kann ich dazu nicht mehr sagen. Ich hab mich oft genug darüber ausgelassen. Oh je. Leute, ich hab Hunger. Ich hab noch nichts gegessen und nicht mal einen Brötchen, nichts. Das Einzige, was ich getrunken hab, ist zwei Gläser Wasser und eine halbe Tasse Tee.
Ich geh jetzt was futtern. Ich geh jetzt was essen. Und dann sehen wir uns. Vielleicht mach ich heute Abend noch eine Runde. Das hängt immer davon ab, wie gut die PvP Action ist. Vielleicht noch eine Runde Best Game Ever heute Abend.
Aber das hängt davon ab, ob BG ab ist, ob Gegner da sind, ob die Fights gut sind. Normales Stream lohnt sich da nicht. Eigentlich BF3.
So Leute, wir sehen uns. Bis denn. See you.